I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies.
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极版《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有亲历者才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室娇娃。
Hello. Hey there. How's it going today? Pretty good. I'm pretty cozy. I see. We've both shown up in our robes today. I am in my pajamas. I slept in this top.
你好。嗨。今天过得怎么样？挺不错的。我挺舒服的。我懂。我们今天都穿了长袍出镜。我穿着睡衣。我睡觉时就穿着这件上衣。
I just put a bra on for you so it wasn't sloppy, sloppy. I want everyone to know we did not plan this, but moments before we were set to start this recording, we're recording from home today. We did not come in today. We're recording from home today. We're recording from home today. We're recording from home today. We're recording from home today.
我刚为了你穿上一件文胸，免得显得太邋遢。我想让大家知道，我们并没有计划这样，但在我们准备开始录音的几分钟前——我们今天是在家里录音。我们今天没去。我们今天在家里录音。我们今天在家里录音。我们今天在家里录音。我们今天在家里录音。
We're recording from home today. We're recording from home today. We're recording from home today. We're recording from home today. We're recording from home today. We're recording from home today. We're recording from home today. We're recording from home today. We're recording from home today. We're recording from home today. wasn't sloppy, sloppy. I want everyone to know we did not plan this, but moments before we were set to start this recording, we're recording from home today. We did not come into the studio in our robes.
我们今天在家里录音。我们今天在家里录音。我们今天在家里录音。我们今天在家里录音。我们今天在家里录音。我们今天在家里录音。我们今天在家里录音。我们今天在家里录音。我们今天在家里录音。我们今天在家里录音。显得太邋遢。我想让大家知道，我们并没有计划这样，但在我们准备开始录音的几分钟前——我们今天是在家里录音。我们没有穿着长袍去工作室。
But moments before I texted Angela and I said, it's been a crazy morning and I don't have time to get dressed. I will be doing this podcast in my pajamas and a robe. And you wrote back, same lady, same. Yes. When I record from home, I record in our little closet, you know, but the closet doesn't have a vent, so it doesn't get any heat.
但在几分钟前，我给安吉拉发短信说，今天早上太忙了，我根本没时间换衣服。我将穿着睡衣和长袍录制这个播客。你回信说：同感，姐妹，同感。没错。当我在家录音时，我是在我们的小壁橱里录的，你知道的，但壁橱里没有通风口，所以一点暖气也没有。
So it's really cold, so I always bundle up. And so we're cozy in our robes. Well, I'm in my pajamas and robe today because I am full on Pam. Leigh is out of town. That's true. And we have talked about what happens to me when he is gone.
所以真的很冷，我总是把自己裹得严严实实的。所以我们穿着长袍感觉很舒服。好吧，我今天穿着睡衣和长袍，因为我完全进入了帕姆的状态。李出城了。确实如此。我们讨论过当他不在家时我会变成什么样。
And this is what happens. He is off skiing with the kids. I don't even have the kids. And I had such a sh-show of the morning with just the pets that I did not have time to get dressed. But it made me think Angela whenever we would come into the studio or come on a zoom and we would be like I had the most insane morning I don't even know what kind of mood I'm in. Sam would always say oh these are my favorite podcasts when y'all come in with this energy. He's like this is gonna
情况就是这样。他和孩子们去滑雪了。我甚至都不用带孩子。今天早上光是应付宠物就让我手忙脚乱，根本没时间换衣服。但这让我想起安吉拉，每当我们去工作室或开着视频会议时，我们都会说：我今天早上遇到了最疯狂的事情，我都不知道自己是什么心情。山姆总是会说：哦，当你们带着这种状态来录播客时，这是我最喜欢的。他说这会
be great. This is no makeup in our robes energy. So here we go. We are here today to talk about Junior Salesmen. It is season nine, episode 13, written by Carrie Kemper and directed by Dave Rogers. Give me a summary pajama, Jenna. Here it is. When David Wallace tasks Dwight to find a temporary replacement for Jim, he interviews all of his friends and family in an effort to avoid hiring Clark and instead create a desk cluster alliance against Pam.
非常棒。这就是不化妆、穿长袍的状态。所以我们开始吧。我们今天在这里讨论《初级推销员》。这是第九季第十三集，由凯莉·肯珀编剧，戴夫·罗杰斯导演。给我一个睡衣版的总结，珍娜。就是这样。当大卫·华莱士委派德怀特为吉姆寻找一个临时替补时，他面试了他的所有朋友和家人，目的是避免雇佣克拉克，转而创建一个针对帕姆的办公桌小集团联盟。
This is really an episode with just an A story. Yeah. Well, didn't start out that way. We'll get to it. That is true. All right, today, Fast Fact 1, 2, and 3 is one Fast Fact. And it is called We Are Halfway Through Season 9. Oh my gosh. Halfway through.
这真的是一个只有单一主线的剧集。是的。嗯，一开始并不是这样的。我们待会儿会讲到。确实如此。好了，今天的第一、第二和第三个冷知识合并成了一个冷知识。它叫做我们已经看完了第九季的一半。天哪。看了一半了。
Yeah. I mean, we- Halfway through. And then there's, halfway through. Yeah. I mean, we- Halfway through, and then that's the show. Yes, if this season was a day of the week, we have just hit Wednesday evening. Thank you for putting it in that analogy for me. We're on hump day. In case everyone out there didn't know what halfway meant. Well, listen, we've been getting a lot of mail from people
对。我是说，我们——看了一半了。然后还有，看了一半了。对。我是说，我们——看了一半，然后这就剧终了。是的，如果这个季节是一周中的一天，我们刚刚迎来了周三的傍晚。谢谢你用这个比喻来向我解释。我们正处于周三。以防外面的每个人都不知道“一半”是什么意思。好吧，听着，我们收到了很多人的来信
on the subject of our rewatch coming to an end, and I wanted to share some of it today. I'm so excited about this because you've told me there's some great letters. There sure were. First up, we got this letter from Mackenzie C. in Atlanta, Georgia, who said, I have been listening to your podcast
关于我们的重温播客即将结束的主题，我今天想分享其中的一些。我对此感到非常兴奋，因为你告诉我有一些很棒的信件。确实有。首先，我们收到了来自佐治亚州亚特兰大的麦肯齐·C的来信，她说，我一直在听你们的播客
since the first episode, and I've gone back and re listened to just like I rewatched the show. It's so funny to go back and listen to earlier episodes where y'all were apologizing about deep dives or going off on random tangents. Now the deep dives are everyone's favorite parts. Well, side note, Mackenzie, we have gotten letters from people who have said when we go on our tangents, it makes them want to throw their phone. There was that guy, but I'm thinking of the guy who wrote us and said he was going to drive his car off the road. He couldn't take it anymore. Yeah, he really does not like them. Yeah. There's been a few. Yeah, but thank you. I think for the most part people enjoy them. But Mackenzie went on to say,
从第一集开始，我回去重新听，就像我重新看这部剧一样。回听早期你们还在为深入探讨或扯到一些随机题外话而道歉的剧集，真是太有趣了。现在深入探讨反而是每个人最喜欢的环节了。好吧，顺便说一句，麦肯齐，我们收到过一些人的来信，他们说当我们扯到题外话时，让他们想把手机扔掉。确实有那个家伙，但我想起那个写信给我们的人，说他要开车冲出马路。他再也受不了了。是的，他真的很不喜欢这些。对。有那么几个人。是的，但谢谢你们。我想大部分人还是很喜欢听的。不过麦肯齐接着说，
and do you remember when y'all didn't have this amazing feature on your website and we all just had to email in our questions? It's crazy how far this podcast has come. Thanks Mackenzie. I mean, yeah, it's definitely been a lot of learning curves, right Jenna? It's come a long way.
你们还记得当年你们的网站上还没有这个神奇的功能，我们所有人都只能发电子邮件来提问的时候吗？这个播客能走到这一步真是太疯狂了。谢谢麦肯齐。我是说，是的，这绝对是一段充满学习曲线的经历，对吧，珍娜？它已经走了很长一段路。
And I feel like it's always evolving. As soon as I think we've found some formula, we mix it up, which I love. Yeah, me too. And I feel like the audience has been on this learning journey with us. Yeah. Well, you know, Mackenzie, speaking
我觉得它一直在演变。每当我以为我们已经找到了某种模式时，我们就会把它打乱，我挺喜欢这样的。是的，我也是。我觉得观众一直和我们一起经历这段学习之旅。是的。好吧，你知道的，麦肯齐，说到
of re-listening to the podcast, we have, Jenna, gotten comments also on our Instagram. Like McKenzie at Michelle Goldruns Trails said, we have been listening to them for so long, I might just go back and re-listen to their re-watch. And at XThayn, not sure if I'm saying that correctly, said, how are we already at season nine? I don't want it to end. I've been re-listening to their re-watch five times. That's amazing. We love you guys.
重听播客，珍娜，我们在Instagram上也收到了评论。就像麦肯齐在Michelle Goldruns Trails留言说的那样，我们听了太久了，我可能要回去重新听他们的重播。@XThayn（不知道我有没有读对）说，我们怎么就已经到第九季了？我不想让它结束。我把他们的重播听了五遍。太惊人了。我们爱你们。
That is so awesome and humbling. And oh my gosh, thank you. Well, before we finish our re-watch, people have some suggestions for us, Angela. This is the suggestion box section. Before we finish our rewatch, people have some suggestions for us, Angela. This is the suggestion box section. I cannot wait to hear these. Karen W. from Sharon, Massachusetts said,
这太棒了，也让人感到谦卑。天哪，谢谢你们。好吧，在我们结束重温之前，大家对我们有一些建议，安吉拉。这就是意见箱环节。在我们结束重温之前，大家对我们有一些建议，安吉拉。这就是意见箱环节。我迫不及待地想听听这些了。来自马萨诸塞州莎伦的凯伦·W说，
I would love to hear you both interview Alison Jones. I would too. Yeah, Karen said, I just listened to the interview with Zach Woods where he talks about her and I want to learn more about her. Thanks for your show." That's a good suggestion. She is wonderful. And you know, I just ran into her. Remember, I was running errands and then I sat down,
我很乐意听到你们俩采访爱莉森·琼斯。我也想。是的，凯伦说，我刚刚听了对扎克·伍兹的采访，他在采访中谈到了她，我想了解更多关于她的信息。谢谢你们的节目。这是一个很好的建议。她太棒了。你知道吗，我刚刚碰到了她。还记得吗，我当时在跑腿，然后我坐下来，
had a cup of tea with her and it was so lovely. All right, that's got to happen. Nicholas J. from Alton, Illinois said, have you considered interviewing someone from standards and practices? Oh, man, I would love to interview the person who was always snarky to Randy Cordray. We got to do that. Well you know, I did that commercial with those guys, that AT&T commercial and in the
和她喝了杯茶，真是太美妙了。好吧，这必须安排上。来自伊利诺伊州奥尔顿的杰克逊·J说，你们有没有考虑过采访标准与实践部门的人？天哪，我很想采访那个总是对兰迪·科德雷冷嘲热讽的人。我们必须得这么做。好吧，你知道的，我跟那些家伙拍过那个广告，那个AT&T的广告，在那个
commercial Brian Baumgartner has a little pug, dog. Guess who brought the pug? Bob Dunn. Bob Dunn's animals. Yes. And I was chatting them up and I told them, we talk about them on the podcast. And I said, would you ever come on?
广告里，布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳有一只小哈巴狗。猜猜是谁把哈巴狗带来的？鲍勃·邓恩。鲍勃·邓恩的动物团队。是的。我和他们闲聊，我告诉他们，我们在播客里谈论过他们。我说，你们会来上节目吗？
We wanna interview you. And this is not Bob Dunn, but this is like the guy who works for Bob Dunn. He was like, sure, I remember coming to the office. He said, man, you know, the hardest animal that we had to work with for you guys was that goose. And I was like, save it for the podcast. Not giant bandit, the biggest cat I've ever held.
我们想采访你们。这人不是鲍勃·邓恩，而是为鲍勃·邓恩工作的人。他说，当然，我记得来过办公室。他说，天哪，你知道为你们这群人工作过的最难对付的动物是那只大鹅吗？我说，留着在播客里说吧。不是巨型班迪特，那是我抱过的最大的猫。
I was shocked. But I was like, now I'm so intrigued. This guy's got to have so many stories. Oh, lady, there's so many people we still want to talk to about the office. I still really want to talk to Timothy Oliphant and I want to talk to Kathy Bates and I want to talk to Jerry Minor.
我当时惊呆了。但我心里想，我现在太好奇了。这家伙一定有好多故事。哦，天哪，还有好多人我们仍然想聊聊《办公室》。我还是真的很想和蒂莫西·奥利芬特聊聊，我想和凯西·贝茨聊聊，我想和杰里·迈纳聊聊。
And I mean, there's so many. I agree. I need to hear from them. All right, listen, more than anything, Angela, we got a lot of mail from people asking us to just keep podcasting in general. Aw. For example, Olivia Kay from Cleveland said,
我的意思是，还有太多人了。我同意。我得听听他们的意见。好吧，听着，安吉拉，最重要的是，我们收到了很多人的来信，请求我们继续做播客。啊。例如，来自克利夫兰的奥利维亚·K说，
dear office ladies, my question is more of a plea. And then in all caps, Olivia wrote, please don't stop your podcast when you run out of office episodes. Olivia went on to say, I've loved listening to you over the years. Your sunny personalities and sweet relationship truly brighten my day every time I listen. You've also had a huge influence on the way I watch all my favorite shows. I'm constantly wondering new things as I watch and I'm often thinking, I wish Angela and
亲爱的办公室娇娃，我的问题更像是一个恳求。然后奥利维亚用全大写字母写道：请在《办公室》的剧集播完后不要停播你们的播客。奥利维亚接着说，这些年我一直很喜欢听你们的节目。每次收听时，你们阳光的性格和甜美的关系真的让我的日子变得明亮。对于我观看所有最喜欢的节目的方式，你们也产生了巨大的影响。我边看边不断地想出新的问题，我经常在想，我希望安吉拉和
Jenna would do a podcast about this show too. So if you need an idea for continuing your podcast, here's my pitch, the rewatch ladies. You could rewatch popular movies and TV shows together and do summaries, deep dives, interviews, all your usual great stuff. Or you could even talk about paint drying
珍娜也能为这个节目做一个播客。所以如果你需要一个继续制作播客的点子，这是我的推销：重温娇娃。你们可以一起重温热门电影和电视剧，做总结、深入探讨、采访，所有你们一贯擅长的精彩内容。或者你们甚至可以谈论油漆变干
and I would still listen. Oh, I love that! They're rewatch ladies! We gotta, okay, that's gotta go on our list. All right, we've got another pitch from Emma Grace from Texas. Hey ladies, will you please add The Edge to your breakdown list? I watched it because of Jenna and it is one of my all-time favorite movies. She's right, so inspirational. I know it'd be stressful but I'll do it for you guys. And finally Larry P from Harrisburg, Pennsylvania said, please do at least one whole episode of The Office Ladies Burn It to the Ground.
我依然会听。哦，我太喜欢这个了！重温娇娃！我们得——好吧，这必须加入我们的清单。好的，我们有来自得克萨斯州的艾玛·格蕾丝的另一个提议。嗨，美女们，请把《边缘》加入你们的剧集剖析列表好吗？我是因为珍娜才看的，这是我历来最喜欢的电影之一。她说得对，太励志了。我知道这会有压力，但为了你们我会看的。最后，来自宾夕法尼亚州哈里斯堡的拉里·P说，请至少做一整集的《办公室娇娃：将其夷为平地》。
whole episode of The Office Ladies, burn it to the ground. You're both so kind and polite and diplomatic 99.999% of the time, but surely there have been occasions when you could have said more, but chose not to. After all these years, aren't you entitled to have a say? Let it out, ladies. Love you both. That's awesome. So we have a lot of ideas here, Ange. We have a lot of ideas. We really do. Well, here's the thing I know, Jenna. I don't want to stop podcasting.
一整集的《办公室娇娃：将其夷为平地》。99.999%的时间里，你们两个都那么善良、礼貌和通情达理，但肯定有过这样的时刻，你们本可以多说点什么，却选择了不说。历经这么多年，难道你们不配拥有发言权吗？释放出来吧，美女们。爱你们两个。这太棒了。所以我们这里有很多点子，安吉拉。我们有很多点子。确实有很多。好吧，我清楚的是，珍娜。我不想停下播客。
I love it. I love doing this with you and I love our office ladies family. I love that I get to spend each week with you all. It's just such a wonderful community and I loved getting to know everyone and I don't want it to stop. I agree. This is my happy place, Ange.
我爱它。我喜欢和你一起做这个，我喜欢我们的办公室娇娃大家庭。我喜欢每周都能和你们大家在一起。这真是一个美好的社区，我喜欢了解这里的每一个人，我不想让它停下来。我同意。这是我的快乐源泉，安吉拉。
It is, it really is. Look at me, I'm in my robe and I just love reading all those letters. I love podcasting with you. And Ange, I'm gonna say something. I'm gonna put it out there. Okay, you know how I feel about reading all those letters. I love podcasting with you. And, Anne, I'm gonna say something. I'm gonna put it out there. Okay. You know how I feel about putting stuff out there. Put it out there.
确实是的。看看我，我穿着长袍，我太喜欢读这些信了。我喜欢和你一起做播客。而且，安吉拉，我要说一件事。我要把它说出来。好吧，你知道我对读这些信的感受。我喜欢和你一起做播客。而且，安吉拉，我要说一件事。我要把它说出来。好吧。你知道我对把事情说出来的感受。说出来吧。
What are you gonna put out there? I'll come in agreement with you. Would it be totally insane for us to go back and re-watch it again and just keep talking about it? Because, listen, I am genuinely curious to go back and watch season it again and just keep talking about it. Because listen, I am genuinely curious to go back and watch season one again. I want to see it now that I have the scope of the whole series in my head.
你要说出什么来？我同意你的看法。我们回头再去重新看一遍，然后继续谈论它，这会不会太疯狂了？因为，听着，我真的很好奇回头再去重新看一遍第一季，然后继续谈论它。因为听着，我真的很好奇回头再去重新看第一季。我想在脑海中有了整个剧集的全局观之后再看它。
I mean, this is what people do. They go back and rewatch. Why can't we just go back and rewatch and keep talking about it? I mean, you're not crazy. There are people that have written in and said this. I have a comment right here. Oh, it's from at Brissa Rodriguez.
我的意思是，这就是人们在做的事。他们会回头重温。为什么我们就不能回头重温并继续谈论它呢？我的意思是，你并不疯狂。已经有人写信说过这个了。我这里就有一个评论。哦，是@布里萨·罗德里格斯发的。
They said, I really need you guys to start from the beginning again. I'm not ready to move on. I mean, see, see, this is what I'm saying. I know. And you know what? I think about all the stuff we didn't have in the beginning. Like I didn't have the DVDs. I didn't have the deleted scenes.
他们说，我真的需要你们从头开始再来一遍。我还没准备好继续往前走。我的意思是，看，看，这就是我要说的。我知道。你知道吗？我想起我们在开始时没有的所有东西。比如我没有DVD。我没有被删减的片段。
We didn't have all the call sheets. We didn't have some of the candy bag alts and the shooting drafts. Like we have gathered information as we've gone. And I know some of those early episodes, we would have more to share. Well, Lady, just the other day, we were out to lunch with Dave Rogers, and he reminded us
我们没有所有的通告单。我们没有一些糖果袋的替代版本和拍摄剧本。就像我们一路走来收集了信息一样。我知道在那些早期剧集中，我们会分享更多内容。好吧，美女，就在前几天，我和戴夫·罗杰斯出去吃午饭，他提醒我们
of a behind the scenes tidbit from Garden Party that we had completely forgotten about. And I'm not even going to say it right now, just in case we really do re-watch it again, I'm going to save it. We already have a Garden Party tidbit, is what I'm saying. That's true. We were so excited at lunch.
关于《花园派对》的一个幕后花絮，我们已经完全忘光了。我甚至现在都不打算说出来，以防我们真的再次重温它，我要把它留到那时。我是说，我们已经有一个《花园派对》的花絮了。确实如此。我们在吃午饭时兴奋极了。
And then I feel like there's just so many more things that are in the world of The Office. There's the webisodes, for example. Yes, people have asked us to break those down. I would like to do that. You won an Emmy for that. I did, for the accountants. Yeah.
然后我觉得在《办公室》的世界里还有太多其他的东西。比如网络短剧。是的，人们要求我们剖析那些。我想做那个。你为此得过艾美奖。我得过，为了《会计师》。是的。
And then you and I both loved the original version. Yes. Why are we not breaking down the British office? I know. Of course. And you know what else? Oh, how about this? Cause I don't know if your phone was blown up, but mine was blown up because there's some new tidbits about the possible spinoff slash reboot.
然后你和我都喜欢原版。是的。为什么我们不剖析英国版的《办公室》？我知道。当然。你知道还有什么吗？哦，这个怎么样？因为我不知道你的手机有没有被打爆，但我的手机被打爆了，因为有一些关于可能的衍生剧或重启版的新花絮。
I mean, they haven't started shooting or anything, but there's a big update. Yeah, you should tell people. All right. So writer Michael Coleman has joined Greg Daniels to co-create the new Office spinoff. Some of you might know Michael because he co-created the series Nathan for You alongside Nathan Fielder. That show is so funny. Did you watch it? It's so funny. That Nathan is so funny. I just sound like my mom.
我是说，他们还没开始拍摄什么的，但有一个重大更新。是的，你应该告诉大家。好吧。因此，编剧迈克尔·科尔曼加入了格雷格·丹尼尔斯的行列，共同创作了新的《办公室》衍生剧。你们中的一些人可能知道迈克尔，因为他与内森·菲尔德共同创作了系列剧《为你效劳》。那个节目太搞笑了。你看过吗？太搞笑了。内森太搞笑了。我听起来就像我妈。
We both did. That was a funny show, people. Oh, I laughed. Oh my goodness. We turned into the two old aunties on that one. Michael has also worked on The Colbert Report, MADtv, Late Night with Conan O'Brien, and a little tidbit. Both Michael and Greg got their starts as writers on Saturday Night Live, But Jenna, we know Michael. We know, know Michael. Yes. We know him very well because he is Ellie Kemper's husband. I'll tell you a sweet thing about Michael. When I was in New York and I was shooting Mean Girls
我们两个都这样。那是个有趣的节目，各位。哦，我笑了。我的天哪。我们在那个节目里变成了两个老阿姨。迈克尔还参与过《科尔伯特报告》、《疯狂电视台》、《柯南·奥布莱恩深夜秀》，还有一个小花絮。迈克尔和格雷格都是作为《周六夜现场》的编剧出道的，但珍娜，我们认识迈克尔。我们非常了解迈克尔。是的。我们对他的情况了如指掌，因为他是艾莉·肯珀的丈夫。我给你讲件关于迈克尔的暖心事。当时我在纽约，我正带着骨折的肩膀拍《贱女孩》
with my broken shoulder, when it was time for me to leave town, I couldn't get my bag down to the car. And Michael, who was nearby, hopped over and grabbed my bag for me and took it down to my car for me. Such a sweetie. Do you see what I'm saying? So nice guy and also very funny. And also someone we could say, Hey, we're going to break down the reboot. We should do it. We have to break down whatever the
当我要离开那个城镇时，我提不动行李下楼。恰好在附近的迈克尔跳过来，帮我把行李拿下来，一直帮我提到车上。真是个大甜心。你明白我的意思吗？人特别好，而且非常幽默。他也是那种我们可以对他说：“嘿，我们要剖析重启版了”的人。我们应该这么做。不管重启的衍生剧最终是什么，我们都必须去剖析它。
reboot spin off ends up being. We definitely need to podcast about that. We will go on set. And we will stock and take notes. Sorry, guys. We're coming. Get ready. And then here's the other thing. I loved doing our Dear Office Ladies episode. I loved when our call to action was right in about your workplace dilemmas. That was so fun. I would love to do more Dear Office Ladies. We could do a lot of themes. We could do BFF advice or wedding advice.
我们绝对需要为之做一个播客。我们要去片场。我们要去偷窥并做笔记。抱歉，各位。我们来了。准备好吧。还有一件事。我喜欢做我们的“亲爱的办公室娇娃”那一集。我喜欢我们的行动号召是直接写信来讲述你们职场上的两难选择。那太有趣了。我很乐意做更多的“亲爱的办公室娇娃”。我们可以做很多主题。我们可以做闺蜜建议或婚礼建议。
I mean, I feel like we could have guests come on and help give us advice. I don't know, this is a lot of options. What we know is that we are not going to stop podcasting. We know that. So how do we pick? I don't know how we pick. I don't know. Can we do all of them? I don't know.
我的意思是，我觉得我们可以邀请嘉宾来帮我们给建议。我不知道，选择太多了。我们知道的是，我们不会停止做播客。我们知道这一点。那我们怎么选呢？我不知道我们怎么选。我不知道。我们可以全都要吗？我不知道。
Maybe we can. Maybe we are, I don't know, guys, Maybe we'll put a poll in stories. What do we do? We do the we rewatch the office again or we rewatch something else or we do dear office ladies Or we do a hybrid. I mean for me my top contenders are Rewatch the office again. I can't believe I'm saying that I know when we started I didn't even know if we'd finished and now I wanna do it again. I would wanna watch other office centered content and Dear Office Ladies,
也许我们可以。也许我们在——我不知道，各位，也许我们会在快讯里放一个投票。我们该怎么办？我们是重新看一遍《办公室》，还是看点别的，或者做“亲爱的办公室娇娃”，还是做个混合版。对我和我来说，我的首选是：再次重温《办公室》。我不敢相信我会这么说，我知道当我们开始时，我甚至不知道我们能否坚持到底，现在我想再做一次。我想看其他以办公室为中心的内容以及“亲爱的办公室娇娃”，
but also maybe a bonus episode where we watch The Edge. Yeah. I don't know, that's not a poll anymore that's doing it all. Well, wait. Cody is commenting. Cody, Cody is saying something. Cody, what are you a poll anymore that's doing it all. Well, wait, Cody is commenting. Cody is saying something.
但也许还有一期我们看《边缘》的彩蛋节目。好吧，那不再是投票了，那是全都要。等等。科迪在发表意见。科迪，科迪在说些什么。科迪，你在说什么？
Cody, what are you saying? Cody, hop on the mic. Cody, as our executive producer, what are your thoughts? Well, I love Dear Office Ladies, number one. But second, it was like when we were starting the podcast, we were trying to find the vibe of the show and what listeners liked. And I was like, well, we could probably redo
科迪，你在说什么？科迪，麦克风交给你。科迪，作为我们的执行制片人，你有什么想法？好吧，我最喜欢“亲爱的办公室娇娃”，排在第一位。但第二，这就像我们刚开始做播客时一样，我们在努力寻找节目的调性和听众喜欢什么。当时我就想，好吧，我们大概可以重做
the first 10, 15 episodes to make them in the style of this episode. And not like the first ones were bad, but it's like, but the styles changed. I don't know. You guys come at it in such a fun, unique way that like we found as we went along, you know? I don't know, just a thought.
前10到15集，让它们的风格符合这一集的风格。倒不是说前几集不好，而是说风格变了。我不知道。你们以一种非常有趣、独特的方式来处理它，就像我们一路走来发现的那样，对吧？我不知道，只是个想法。
Take it or leave it. All right. We like it. I take it. We take it. We redo the beginning. All right, to sum up, we love you all and we want to hear from you. We do. We are halfway through season nine and we want to hear what you want us to do next. We're here for you. We should probably start making a plan. So we'd love to hear your thoughts. For now, why don't we take a break, and then when we come back, we will start talking about junior salesmen.
接受与否随你们。好吧。我们喜欢。我接受。我们接受。我们重做开头。好吧，总结一下，我们爱你们所有人，我们想听到你们的声音。我们确实想。我们已经看完了第九季的一半，我们想听听你们希望我们接下来做什么。我们一直都在。我们大概应该开始制定一个计划了。所以我们很想听听你们的想法。现在，我们为什么不休息一下，等回来后，我们开始讨论《初级推销员》。
Let's do it. ["Junior Salesmen Theme Song"] This episode starts with such a juicy moment. The camera is rolling, but it's sitting on the floor. And from the waist down, we see like two sets of legs and feet, right? And it's Pam and the boom operator, Brian. And Pam is kind of apologizing to him
我们开始吧。[《初级推销员》主题曲] 这一集的开场是一个非常精彩的瞬间。摄像机在拍摄，但它放在地板上。从腰部以下，我们看到两组腿和脚，对吧？那是帕姆和收音师布莱恩。帕姆有点在向他道歉
for getting him into trouble. And he's saying, you know, how are you and Jim doing? And then Erin says, Pam, you know, you have a phone call and she kind of leaves. Meredith of course has to hit on Brian the boom guy, which apparently she's been doing for a while because he's like, Meredith, you know what? They're telling us we can't really talk to you guys anymore.
因为连累了他惹上麻烦。他说，你知道，你和吉姆最近怎么样？然后艾琳说，帕姆，你知道的，你有电话，然后她就离开了。梅雷迪思当然得去撩一下收音师布莱恩，显然她这么做已经有一段时间了，因为他说：梅雷迪思，你知道吗？他们告诉我们，我们真的不能再跟你们多说话了。
It's true. I have one quick background catch at 33 seconds. I'm calling this a sensible shoe catch. What is it? Did you see Pam's heels? I mean, is it 1960? I feel like my grandmother who loved a sensible shoe, Lena Mackenzie, loved a sensible shoe. I feel like she would be like, that's a very sensible high heel, Pam Beasley.
确实如此。在33秒的时候，我有一个快速的背景捕捉。我称之为“实用鞋履捕捉”。是什么？你看到帕姆的高跟鞋了吗？我是说，这是1960年代吗？我觉得我的祖母很喜欢实用鞋履，莉娜·麦肯齐很喜欢实用鞋履。我觉得她会说，那是一双非常实用的高跟鞋，帕姆·比斯利。
That is a working woman's shoe. It's a sensible shoe catch. We got some fan mail about this cold open, Angela. Oh, I bet we did. This first one is from Shalee D in Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania. Hi, Shalee. You write in every episode, every episode you send us questions, multiple questions. And they're always so good. Yeah.
那是职业女性的鞋子。这是一个实用鞋履捕捉。安吉拉，我们收到了一些关于这个冷开场的粉丝来信。哦，我敢打赌我们肯定收到了。这第一封信来自宾夕法尼亚州匹兹堡的莎莉·D。嗨，莎莉。你每一集都写信，每一集你都会给我们发问题，好几个问题。而且总是那么好。是的。
Shaili said, Does Pam make sure to ask about Alyssa when she's talking to Brian just to let the viewers know that nothing happened between her and Brian? Was Brian's original storyline going to be that he would have been trouble for Jim and Pam's relationship? Oh, Shaylee. Yes. Yes. Tell us, Jenna. Spill the tea. Well, a ridg— That's what they say, right? You spill the tea. Do you serve the tea? No.
莎莉说，帕姆在跟布莱恩说话时，是不是确保问到了艾莉莎的情况，只是为了让观众知道她和布莱恩之间什么都没发生？布莱恩最初的故事情节是不是要成为吉姆和帕姆关系的麻烦？哦，莎莉。是的。是的。告诉我们吧，珍娜。爆料吧。好吧，一个瑞——他们是这么说的，对吧？爆料。你是上茶吗？不。
Or do you spill it? You spill the tea. Is it because when I was drinking my tea, you told me such a good gossip moment that I spilled it? Is that what spilling the tea is? I don't know, but I did just- It doesn't matter though. It doesn't matter. I did just learn what the ick is.
还是你把它泼了？你爆料（泼茶）。是因为我喝茶时，你告诉了我一个那么棒的八卦，结果我洒了吗？这就是“爆料”（spill the tea）的意思吗？我不知道，但我刚刚——这不重要。这不重要。我刚刚知道了什么是“让人倒胃口”（the ick）。
What's the ick? The ick. Okay, my teenagers told me, it's like, if you like someone and you're like, oh my gosh, they're great, they're great. And then all of a sudden they do something and you're like, ick. That's the ick. Oh, like if you like someone and you're like, oh my gosh, they're great, they're great. And then all of a sudden they do something and you're like, ick. That's the ick.
什么是“让人倒胃口”？“让人倒胃口”。好吧，我的十几岁的孩子们告诉我，这就像，如果你喜欢某个人，你会觉得，哦天哪，他们太棒了，太棒了。然后突然之间他们做了一件事，你就会觉得：真下头（ick）。这就是“让人倒胃口”。哦，就像如果你喜欢某个人，你会觉得，哦天哪，他们太棒了，太棒了。然后突然之间他们做了一件事，你就会觉得：真下头。这就是“让人倒胃口”。
Oh, like if you like them, but then maybe you go on a date and they chew with their mouth open, that's the ick. Yeah, then all of a sudden it's like the ick. Anyway, anyway, I don't think Pam has the ick about Brian. I think Pam cares for him as a friend. Yes, that is true. And originally in the script, in fact, in this scene as scripted, Pam tells Brian she talked to Alyssa about what's going on with her and Jim, and that Alyssa sort of took Jim's side, and they have a whole banter about how that's typical of Alyssa and they kind of
哦，就像如果你喜欢他们，但也许你约会时发现他们嚼东西时嘴巴大张着，这就让人倒胃口。对，然后突然之间就像是倒胃口。不管怎样，不管怎样，我不认为帕姆对布莱恩有那种倒胃口的感觉。我觉得帕姆作为朋友很关心他。是的，确实如此。原本在剧本中，事实上在这一集的剧本里，帕姆告诉布莱恩，她跟艾莉莎谈过她和吉姆之间发生的事情，艾莉莎有点站在吉姆那边，他们有一大段关于这很符合艾莉莎风格的互动，然后他们有点
laugh about it. And what we were trying to do with that storytelling was express that Alyssa and Brian are like couple friends with Jim and Pam. Yeah. And that Brian comforting Pam was like as if your friend's husband was comforting you in a difficult moment. But we ended up cutting it out and making it simpler and just having Pam reference Alyssa. I think that's good. I think that was a good cut. Yeah. We also got mail from Clara D in Germany who said,
笑了起来。我们试图通过这种叙事表达的是，艾莉莎和布莱恩就像是吉姆和帕姆的夫妻朋友。是的。布莱恩安慰帕姆，就好像你朋友的丈夫在困难时刻安慰你一样。但我们最终把它剪掉了，让它变得更简单，只让帕姆提到了艾莉莎。我觉得这很好。我觉得这是一个很好的剪辑。是的。我们还收到了来自德国的克拉拉·D的信，她说，
probably not a very niche opinion, but the Brian storyline dot dot dot. It feels physically painful to watch. Do you remember the fan reactions when these episodes first came out? Oh wow, Clara. From the moment Brian appeared, fans went completely berserk. I mean, they lost their minds. I mean, they lost their minds. Their reaction was so much stronger than we ever expected, and we actually started scrambling
这大概不是什么小众观点，但布莱恩的故事线……看的时候感觉身体上都很痛苦。还记得这些剧集刚播出时的粉丝反应吗？哦，天哪，克拉拉。从布莱恩出现的那一刻起，粉丝们就彻底抓狂了。我是说，他们失去了理智。我是说，他们失去了理智。他们的反应比我们预期的要强烈得多，我们实际上开始手忙脚乱地
and pulling back on some of the plans we had because just this spy shot of the two of them talking where Pam even references Alyssa, people got so upset. You know, our longtime editor, Dave Rogers, who Jenna and I just had lunch with, he directed this episode, right? and I just had lunch with, he directed this episode, right? And we were catching up with him, and we told him we were about to break down this episode.
缩减我们原本的一些计划，因为仅仅是他们俩交谈的一个谍照，其中帕姆甚至提到了艾莉莎，人们就变得如此沮丧。你知道吗，我们的长期剪辑师戴夫·罗杰斯，我和珍娜刚刚跟他吃过午饭，他导演了这一集，对吧？我和珍娜刚刚跟他吃过午饭，他导演了这一集，对吧？我们在跟他叙旧，我们告诉他我们正准备剖析这一集。
He's going to share a bunch of audio clips. But the first thing we asked him was about this Pam Bryan storyline, and here's what he had to say. I have a pretty strong opinion on the Pam-Brian arc. I don't have any issues with Brian being a potential threat to Jim and Pam's relationship. He's supposed to be. He's supposed to, you know, that's what he was there for was to, you know, be someone like, oh is this is this gonna put a deeper wedge in between Jim and Pam who are already fighting? But that never bothered me.
他要分享一堆音频片段。但我们问他的第一件事就是关于这个帕姆-布莱恩的故事线，以下是他的看法。对于帕姆和布莱恩的发展弧线，我有一个相当坚定的看法。对于布莱恩是否会成为吉姆和帕姆关系潜在威胁这件事，我没有任何异议。他本来就应该是。他本应该，你知道的，他存在就是为了，你知道的，成为那种人，比如“哦，这会给吉姆和帕姆本就在争吵的关系之间打下更深的楔子吗？”但这从来没有困扰过我。
I had no issues with that. And I had no issues. I loved how Brian shows up for the first time. I loved the reveal of Brian. To me, it's mind blowing. It's like, oh my God. And we left the episode at the end of that. And then it's, you know, then what's going to happen next?
我对此没有任何异议。而且我也毫无异议。我喜欢布莱恩第一次出现的方式。我喜欢布莱恩的亮相。对我来说，这太震撼了。就像是，哦天哪。我们在那一集的结尾停了下来。然后，你知道的，接下来会发生什么呢？
And that's what I have issues with. That we kind of retconned him in, that suddenly we have this character that we've never seen before, that Jim and Pam have had this relationship with. And that bothered me, like that they knew him and that they were friendly with him and his wife. I just had a lot of trouble with that.
这就是让我感到有问题的地方。我们有点硬把他加了进去，突然之间我们有了这样一个以前从未见过的角色，而吉姆和帕姆却跟他有过这种关系。这让我很困扰，比如他们认识他，而且他们和他的妻子关系很友好。我对此感到非常困惑。
It didn't feel real to me. Like we know so much about them. We were with them every day, you know, when watching the show and all these components of their life. And then suddenly there's this, you know, this character that supposedly has been there the whole time. I mean, I guess it's plausible, but I struggled with that. Dave, I hear you. I hear what you're saying. Yeah. And we did discuss this when we were kind of playing out this storyline. And I guess the excuse we came up with
这对我来说感觉不真实。就像我们对他们了解太多了。我们在看剧以及他们生活的各个方面时，每天都和他们在一起，你知道的。然后突然有了这样一个据称一直都在那里的角色。我的意思是，我想这还算说得过去，但我对此感到纠结。戴夫，我听到你的声音了。我明白你的意思。是的。当我们构思这个故事线时，我们确实讨论过这个问题。我想我们想出的借口是
is that we haven't really followed any of Jim and Pam's real life friends unless they showed up at an occasion, like, for example, the christening, or maybe how Jim's friend came in to play a prank on Dwight. Like we don't know a lot about their personal lives or their personal friends. So that's how we thought we could get away with it. I would even say there's times where we've gotten a little nugget even in deleted scenes that like Jim might make his usual salmon.
除了偶尔出席某些场合的朋友外，我们并没有真正关注过吉姆和帕姆的任何现实生活中的朋友，比如，洗礼仪式，或者吉姆的朋友怎么来捉弄德怀特。就像我们对他们的个人生活或个人朋友知之甚少。所以这就是我们以为可以蒙混过关的方式。我甚至会说，有时我们甚至能在被删减的片段中得到一点小线索，比如吉姆可能会做他常做的三文鱼。
And we're like, oh, Jim makes salmon. We really don't know about their lives at home. Like, yeah. So that wasn't as big a jump for me. It was just weird though to see such a cutie patootie who had been, I guess, there with Pam all along. He's very fit, Chris. He's like super fit. Yes, the cutie patootie that you are referring to is Chris Diamantopoulos, who played Brian the Boom Operator. And it occurred to me that I hadn't done
然后我们会想，哦，吉姆会做三文鱼。我们真的对他们在家的生活一无所知。所以对我来说，这不算是一个太大的跨度。不过，看到这样一个可爱的小帅哥一直陪在帕姆身边，还是觉得有点奇怪。他身材非常好，克里斯。他超级健康。是的，你所指的那个可爱的小帅哥就是克里斯·迪亚曼托普洛斯，他饰演了收音师布莱恩。我突然意识到我还没有好好地
a good introduction of him, because we're hoping to have him on the pod. Yes. But I will say, I did read with him. I did auditions with all of the final contenders for Brian the Boom Guy. And this was one of those times when, just like when I read with Rashida for Karen, it was like, oh, it's you. Of course it's you.
介绍一下他，因为我们希望能邀请他上播客。是的。但我得说，我确实跟他一起对过词。我跟所有饰演布莱恩的最后候选人一起试镜过。那是那种时刻之一，就像当初我跟雷希达一起为凯伦试镜时一样，当时的感觉是：哦，就是你。当然是你。
Like, he ran away with it. And he was so wonderful. And you know, here's a little tidbit of trivia about him. He does a ton of voiceover work, like a ton. And he is the voice of Mickey Mouse. No way. Yes. If you go to Disneyland and you ride the ride
就像他直接脱颖而出一样。他太棒了。你知道吗，关于他有一个小小的冷知识。他做了大量的配音工作，真的超级多。他就是米老鼠的配音。不会吧。是的。如果你去迪士尼乐园并游玩
Mickey and Minnie's Runaway Railway, that's him as Mickey Mouse. But he's also like the current voice of Mickey Mouse and all kinds of animated stuff. That is making my brain go, what? Because it's like, because I just picture him, I don't see that voice. That's crazy. Yeah, and I would make him talk to me as Mickey Mouse on set because it was, it was, I mean, it's crazy if you close your eyes, it's Mickey Mouse. That's wild.
米奇和米妮的逃奇之旅，那里面米老鼠的声音就是他配的。但他也是各种动画作品中米老鼠的现任配音。这让我的大脑有点宕机，因为我觉得，因为我脑海里想象着他，但我听不出那是那种声音。太疯狂了。是的，我会让他在片场用米老鼠的声音跟我说话，因为这太——我的意思是，如果你闭上眼睛，这太疯狂了，这就是米老鼠。太疯狂了。
I don't know if he comes on the pod if he'll be allowed to do it or not. Oh, he might not be allowed to, but we can like play a little bit of Mickey Mouse, like, oh, maybe we can find an audio clip of him doing it. Okay, guys. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Just know that's Mickey Mouse, Brian the Boom Guy. Does that make it easier to like him knowing that? Maybe when you watch the show?
我不知道他如果上播客的话允不允许这样做。哦，他可能不被允许，但我们可以放一小段米老鼠的声音，比如，哦，也许我们可以找到一段他配音的音频。好吧，各位。是的，是的，是的。只要知道那是米老鼠，收音师布莱恩就行了。知道了这一点，会不会觉得更容易喜欢他一点？也许在你看剧的时候？
You're like, I can't hate Mickey Mouse. Oh man, but they definitely can hate Brian the Boom Guy. I felt bad for him. It was like him and Lindsay. Man, they got so much heat for playing these characters. Oh. I think that Chris, Lindsay, Rich Summer, and Rashida Jones should all go out to dinner sometime
你会想，我不能讨厌米老鼠。天哪，但他们绝对可以讨厌收音师布莱恩。我为他感到难过。就像他和琳赛一样。天哪，他们因为饰演这些角色而挨了太多骂。哦。我觉得克里斯、琳赛、里奇·萨默和雷希达·琼斯应该抽空一起吃个晚饭
and talk about what it's like to play a character trying to come between Jim and Pam. Oh. I'd love to record that dinner. Yeah. Well, this episode is gonna start with Clark approaching Dwight in the break room. He heard that Dwight is going to be interviewing people for a new sales position and Clark would like to get the job.
聊聊夹在吉姆和帕姆中间去扮演一个角色是什么感觉。哦。我很想把那顿饭录下来。是的。好吧，这一集从克拉克在休息室接近德怀特开始。他听说德怀特要为一个新的销售职位面试人选，克拉克想得到这份工作。
Yeah, basically Dwight has to find someone to temporarily take Jim's place while Jim is in Philly. And Dwight is really excited. He's looking forward to having someone at his desk clump that really gets him, you know? Yeah, he says, you know, like someone who knows the difference between a slaughterhouse and a rendering plant.
是的，基本上德怀特必须找一个人在吉姆在费城期间临时取代他的位置。德怀特非常兴奋。他很期待他的办公桌区域能有一个真正懂他的人，你知道吗？是的，他说，你知道的，就像那种知道屠宰场和渲染厂区别的人。
Duh, Jim. I looked it up. Did you really? I mean, I knew what a slaughterhouse was because it's in the name, you really? I mean, I knew what a slaughterhouse was because it's in the name, you know? That's where you slaughter animals. But I was like, what's a rendering plant? Do you wanna know?
废话，吉姆。我查过了。真的吗？我是说，我知道什么是屠宰场，因为名字里就带着，真的吗？我是说，我知道什么是屠宰场，因为名字里就带着，你知道的？那是你屠宰动物的地方。但我当时想，什么是渲染厂？你想知道吗？
Is that where they repurpose parts of the animals? Yes. Yes, that's exactly right. Didn't know that. Neither did Jim. That's right. I have a call sheet tidbit for you. What is it?
那是他们重新利用动物身体部位的地方吗？是的。是的，完全正确。我以前不知道。吉姆也不知道。没错。我有一个通告单的小花絮要告诉你。是什么？
Our first day of filming this episode was Monday, December 12th, 2012. The high was of 68 degrees and the low was 47. That would be our average weather for this whole entire week. And I want you to know when Steve Burgess sent me the call sheets, he included a photo from his yard. So I sent him back one of my yard. And we now do this every week. We sent each other a Snapchat from our yard. I asked him if I could share them and he said yes. Oh, well, lady, we've started doing this as well. When I sent him my fan questions and production questions, he now sends me back a photo as well.
我们拍摄这一集的第一天是2012年12月12日，星期一。最高气温是68华氏度，最低是47华氏度。这差不多是我们整个星期的平均天气。我想让你们知道，当史蒂夫·伯吉斯把通告单发给我时，他附上了一张他院子里的照片。所以我回发了一张我院子里的照片。我们现在每周都这么做。我们互相发送一张来自各自院子的快照。我问他我能不能分享这些照片，他说可以。哦，天哪，我们现在也开始这么做了。当我把粉丝问题和制作问题发给他时，他现在也会回我一张照片。
I love it! He's the cutest human. Clark is really going to pitch himself for this job. He reminds Dwight of some of the sacrifices that he has gone through for Dunder Mifflin in his short time here. that he has gone through for Dunder Mifflin in his short time here. But Dwight has a talking head where he says, Clark has no chance. Dwight is going to interview Rolf, who fishes with hand grenades, and Trevor, who will laugh so hard you'll puke your pants.
我太喜欢了！他是最可爱的人。克拉克真的在为这份工作推销自己。他提醒德怀特，在这短短的时间里，他为了邓德·米夫林经历了一些牺牲。但他有一个面向镜头的独白，他说，克拉克没有机会。德怀特要去面试用手榴弹钓鱼的罗尔夫，以及会笑到让你把裤子都吐出来的特雷弗。
Here's something that Dave shared with us on our lunch, Jenna, which is that in the initial draft, Rolf wasn't included, remember? Yes. And that Dave was like, what? You can't not have Rolf. And Dave pitched so hard to have the character of Rolf be in this episode.
这是戴夫在午饭时跟我们分享的一个花絮，珍娜，那就是在最初的草稿中，罗尔夫是没有被包含进来的，还记得吗？是的。戴夫当时说，什么？你怎么能没有罗尔夫呢。戴夫极力争取让罗尔夫这个角色出现在这一集里。
And I have to say some of my favorite moments are of Rolf. Well, on that note, I have a little tidbit that Dave shared with us for a scene that comes later. I'll save it. Save it? It's about Rolf. It is. I need everyone to go to two minutes and 20 seconds. What for? Dwight has super flat, like, flatty flat bangs, like super flatty bangs. Did he have a hat on? No, I think maybe someone got a new flat iron in the hair and makeup trailer. Please note, flatty bangs at two minutes, 20 seconds.
我不得不说，我最喜欢的一些时刻都是关于罗尔夫的。顺便说一句，我有一个小花絮，是戴夫跟我们分享的一个随后出现的场景的。我先留着不说。留着不说？是关于罗尔夫的。是的。我需要每个人都把进度条拉到2分20秒。干嘛？德怀特有超级平的、就像超平超平的刘海，就像超级平的刘海。他戴帽子了吗？没有，我想可能是化妆造型车厢里有人有了个新夹板。请注意，在2分20秒时的超平刘海。
They're real flat. Well, next up, Dwight and his flatty bangs are gonna antagonize Jim and Pam. He's gonna tell them there's gonna be a new alliance and it's gonna be Dwight and a friend against Pam. Pam is sort of worried. Jim has a talking head. I don't know, it kind of annoyed me.
它们真的很平。好吧，接下来，德怀特和他的超平刘海要去挑衅吉姆和帕姆。他要告诉他们将会有个新联盟，将由德怀特和一个朋友组成来对抗帕姆。帕姆有点担心。吉姆有一个面向镜头的独白。我不知道，这让我有点恼火。
I felt like he was a little bit flippant. He says, things between me and Pam are delicate, so adding more Dwight to her life could only make things worse. What bothered you about that? It just seems like a little blase about the state of affairs, if you will. Like a little bit of like to the camera, like, oh, things are kind of crappy with the Mrs.
我觉得他有点轻率。他说，我和帕姆之间的关系很微妙，所以给她的生活增加更多德怀特只会让情况变得更糟。这有什么让你生气的？这看起来就像是对局势有点漫不经心，如果你懂的话。就像有点冲着镜头说，哦，跟这位太太在一起情况有点糟糕。
What? Oh, Bippity whoopsies. Oh, boy. You do not usually get so hot to trot about, Jim, but here you are. Maybe it's because I'm in my cozy pajamas and my robe. It's starting. I'm just really comfortable. Sam, if you're listening, it's starting. Yeah, Sam.
什么？哦，天哪，真冒失。噢，天呐。吉姆，你平时可不会这么激动，但你现在就是这样。也许是因为我穿着舒适的睡衣和长袍。开始了。我真的很舒服。萨姆，如果你在听的话，开始啦。没错，萨姆。
So Clark and Rolf are now in the conference room and they're waiting to interview. This is now the waiting room. Although Rolf says to Clark, you're interviewing, I'm getting the job, which was very funny. Yeah. Dwight now has a talking head where he says
所以克拉克和罗尔夫现在在会议室里，等着面试。这里现在成了候诊室。虽然罗尔夫对克拉克说，你是来面试的，而工作是我的，这非常搞笑。是的。德怀特现在有一个面对镜头的独白，他说
Rolf is his best friend and he's the man. Cool, calm, collected, sweet guy, can't be rattled. And then this cuts to a scene where Ralph is just yelling, like yelling at the sweetest little bunny. He's like, he's bending over in the grass, yelling at a bunny. We got a fan question from Stacy F in Santa Cruz, California, who said that bunny that Ralph is yelling at at three minutes and 36 seconds is perfect. Please tell me about the bunny actor and how the Wranglers got the bunny to turn away from Rolf as he is yelling at it. Well, Stacey, Steve Burgess told me that the bunny was from Bob Dunn. And if we get to interview Bob Dunn,
罗尔夫是他最好的朋友，而且他是个真正的汉子。冷静、沉着、从容、温柔的家伙，泰山崩于前而色不变。然后镜头切到一个场景，拉尔夫居然在冲一只最可爱的小兔子大喊大叫，就像是在大吼大叫。他弯着腰站在草地上，对一只兔子大喊。我们收到了来自加利福尼亚州圣克鲁斯市的斯黛西·F的粉丝提问，她说拉尔夫在三分36秒时对着大吼的那只兔子太完美了。请告诉我关于那只兔子演员的事情，以及驯兽师是怎么让兔子在拉尔夫对它大吼时转过头去的。嗯，斯黛西，史蒂夫·伯吉斯告诉我那只兔子来自鲍勃·邓恩。如果我们能采访到鲍勃·邓恩，
we will ask them, how do you train a bunny to disregard someone who is yelling at them? I don't have that answer now, but Steve said that Bob Dunn not only brought the bunny, but they also brought the rabbit poop. What? Yeah, that was surrounding the bunny. Steve Burgess says the bunny was $150. The trainer fee was $600. Transportation for the bunny was $250 and the poop was free.
我们会问他们，你是怎么训练兔子对冲它大吼的人置之不理的？我现在没有这个答案，但史蒂夫说鲍勃·邓恩不仅带来了兔子，还带来了兔子的粪便。什么？对，就是围在兔子周围的那些。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说兔子花了150美元。驯兽师费用是600美元。兔子的运输费是250美元，而粪便则是免费的。
The transportation costs more than the bunny. Yes, it was more expensive to transport the bunny than the bunny charges to act. Yeah. Yeah. It's a good thing the bunny can't read. He didn't get a good deal. He didn't. Everyone else made more money. Jim is now on the phone. He's assuring his athlete teammate
运费比兔子还贵。是的，运送兔子的费用比兔子出场演出的费用还要高。没错。这兔子的好处是它不识字。它可没谈成什么好买卖。确实没有。其他所有人赚的钱都比它多。吉姆现在在打电话。他向他的运动员队友
that he will talk to David Wallace today, but says, don't get your hopes up. And we learned that athlete lost a really big investor last week. And his coworkers want Jim to ask David Wallace for some money. That's going to be awkward. Yeah, so he says they lost a big investor last week.
保证他今天会跟大卫·华莱士谈谈，但也说，别抱太大希望。我们得知那个运动员上周失去了一个非常大的投资者。他的同事们想让吉姆找大卫·华莱士要点资金。那可真够尴尬的。对，所以他说他们上周失去了一个大投资者。
Remember, they also lost a big investor when Jim couldn't drive home for the recital. So have they lost two big investors now? I'm worried for Athlead. I know. Well, Rolf and Dwight now loudly, very loudly approach the desk clump where Dwight and Jim and Pam sit. Dwight's saying that chair is going to be yours and this desk and Jim's trying to talk on the phone. And Jim's like, I'm on the phone. And Dwight goes, no, doi. Who says that anymore? Who says no doi? Is that out? I think that's out. You know what that is? That's an ick.
记住，当吉姆无法开车回家参加独奏会时，他们也失去过一个大投资者。所以他们现在已经失去两个大投资者了吗？我开始为Athlead担心了。我知道。好吧，罗尔夫和德怀特现在大声地、非常大声地走向德怀特、吉姆和帕姆坐着的办公桌区。德怀特说那把椅子会是你的，还有这张桌子，而吉姆正试图打电话。吉姆说，我在打电话呢。德怀特却来了一句：“不，哎哟。”现在谁还这么说？谁还会说“不，哎哟”？这已经过时了吧？我觉得这已经过时了。你知道那是什么吗？那是让人倒胃口的表现。
That's an ick. Well, Rolf says to Pam, You better like Norwegian black metal because I don't wear earbuds. So that's what's in store for Pam. If Rolf gets the job, and you know, Pam tries to brush it off. She says, you know what, it's just a seating arrangement. It doesn't matter. And that kind of hits Jim. He's like, oh, well, next up in Andy's office, Dwight is going to look over Rolf's resume. This was my favorite interview of all the ones that Dwight did. And I think we need to hear it. So I've got your resume here, but it's not telling me everything. A lot of the information is private.
让人倒胃口。好吧，罗尔夫对帕姆说：“你最好喜欢挪威黑金属音乐，因为我不戴耳塞。”所以这就是等待帕姆的命运。如果罗尔夫得到了这份工作，你知道的，帕姆试图轻描淡写地带过。她说，你知道吗，这只是一种座位安排而已。这没关系。这话有点触动了吉姆。他心想，哦，好吧，安迪办公室的下一个环节是，德怀特要审阅罗尔夫的简历。这是德怀特进行的所有面试中我最喜欢的一场。我觉得我们有必要听听看。所以我有你的简历，但它并没有说明全部情况。很多信息都是私密的。
How do I know you're qualified to evaluate me? No one offering the job. What are your credentials? I've worked here for 12 years. One salesman of the year, an assistant to the regional manager. I think I've heard everything I need to hear. Wait, wait, wait. No. I mean, if you need to know more, you can call David Wallace.
我怎么知道你有没有资格评估我？又不是你提供这份工作。你有什么资历？我在这里工作了 12 年。获得过年度最佳销售员，地区经理助理。我想我已经听到我需要听的一切了。等等，等等，等等。不。我的意思是，如果你需要了解更多，你可以打电话给大卫·华莱士。
I'm sure you'd give a reference. Thank you, Dwight. I'll be in touch. Well, they can't all be winners. I love it so much. I really want to have an interview where I hand over a resume and I've redacted it. There's like redacted those black bars. How do I know you're qualified to know these things about me? I just loved it. James Urbaniak is so great as Rolf.
我确信他会为你提供推荐信。谢谢你，德怀特。我会保持联系的。好吧，不可能人人都是赢家。我太喜欢了。我真的很想进行一次面试，递上一份我涂黑了信息的简历。就像那种被黑色条块涂黑的。我怎么知道你是否有资格了解关于我的这些事情？我太喜欢了。詹姆斯·乌尔巴尼亚克演的罗尔夫太棒了。
That's another person I would like to talk to on the podcast. Yes. See, next time we rewatch this episode, we'll have James Urbaniak on. That's right. The redo of the rewatch is writing itself. Well, next up is Trevor. Yeah, and apparently Trevor is a real professional who loves to jump on people, like he actually jumps on people. Yeah, in his interview, Trevor seems
那是我希望在播客中采访的另一个人。是的。看，下次我们重温这一集时，我们就邀请詹姆斯·乌尔巴尼亚克来。没错。重温剧集的重温节目已经在筹备中了。好吧，接下来是特雷弗。是的，显然特雷弗是一个真正的专业人士，喜欢往人身上扑，他是真的会扑到人身上那种。是的，在面试中，特雷弗似乎
blindsided by the fact that he's going to be asked questions. He has clearly never interviewed for anything before, I guess. And we got a fan question from Carly O in Chicago, Illinois, who said, wouldn't Oscar recognize Trevor and be mad that he's interviewing at Dunder Mifflin after trying to break his kneecaps? Yeah. Carly, if you look in the background over Trevor's shoulder, kind of through the blinds, you can see Aaron and Oscar at reception looking in on the interview.
被自己要被提问这件事搞得措手不及。我猜他显然从来没有面试过任何工作。我们收到了来自伊利诺伊州芝加哥市的卡莉·O的粉丝提问，她说，难道奥斯卡不会认出特雷弗，并对他在试图捏碎奥斯卡的膝盖之后还来邓德米夫林面试感到生气吗？是的。卡莉，如果你看特雷弗肩膀后面的背景，透过百叶窗隐约可以看到，你能看到艾伦和奥斯卡在前台注视着这场面试。
So I think that this was meant to express Oscar's concern. Yeah, I think you're right. Clark and Jim are now going to have a moment. Clark asked Jim for permission to review the price sheets before his interview. And Jim wants to see if Clark's gonna be a good deskmate for Pam and he's liking him. And of course, Dwight sees this and he does not like that. He says, you know what?
所以我认为这旨在表达奥斯卡的担忧。是的，我想你是对的。克拉克和吉姆现在要有个单独交流的时刻了。克拉克请求吉姆允许他在面试前查看价格表。而吉姆想看看克拉克会不会成为帕姆一个好的办公桌同伴，他挺喜欢克拉克的。当然，德怀特看到了这一幕，他对此很不高兴。他说，你知道吗？
I can't hire Clark. He may look like a shrewt, but he thinks like a Halport and he acts like a Beasley. That's right. Clark is now in Dwight's office and he is doing a good job at this interview that Dwight is really trying to make him fail. That's right. He's asking him a whole bunch of questions and then Clark says that's just a classic no-win situation so I'd Kobayashi Maru it.
我不能雇佣克拉克。他看起来可能像个 shrewt（精明鬼），但他思考起来像个 Halport（哈尔伯特），行为举止又像个 Beasley（比斯利）。没错。克拉克现在在德怀特的办公室里，他在这场德怀特极力想让他失败的面试中表现得很出色。没错。德怀特问了他一大堆问题，然后克拉克说，这只是一个典型的无解困境，所以我会用“小林丸”策略来应对。
And Dwight says damn it. Perfect answer again. Were you wondering what that meant? I was. Well, then you'll be happy that we got a letter from Anne-Marie Kay in London, because Anne-Marie Kay, thank you very much, is gonna explain it to us. Is it Kobayashi from The Usual Suspects? No, it is a Star Trek reference.
德怀特说，该死。又是一个完美的回答。你刚才在想那是什么意思吗？我是。好吧，那你一定会高兴的，因为我们收到了来自伦敦的安妮-玛丽·凯的一封信，因为安妮-玛丽·凯，非常感谢你，将为我们解释这个。这是《非常嫌疑犯》里的小林丸吗？不，这是一个《星际迷航》的梗。
Oh. Mm-hmm. Anne-Marie said, this is a very quick exchange between Dwight and Clark, but since my husband is a huge Star Trek fan and I am an Office fan, I got him to explain this reference and I did a deep dive for you. Thank you. The Kobayashi Maru is the name of a stranded ship from a Star Trek training simulation. In this training simulation, the ship has lost power and it is drifted into enemy Klingon space. Crossing into enemy space will be seen as an act of war. But it's not a real ship. This is a simulation. It's a simulation. However, in the simulation, if you don't cross into this enemy territory, a hundred people will die. In real life or in the simulation? In the simulation. So the simulation is asking you, what do you do? What do you do when there's no good right answer? Oh, you Kobayashi Maruit. Yes, Captain Kirk famously hacked the simulation, lowering
哦。嗯哼。安妮-玛丽说，这是德怀特和克拉克之间非常简短的一段对话，但由于我丈夫是个超级《星际迷航》迷，而我是《办公室》迷，我让他给我解释了这个梗，并为你做了一次深度挖掘。谢谢。小林丸是《星际迷航》训练模拟程序中一艘搁浅飞船的名字。在这个训练模拟中，飞船失去了动力，漂入了敌方克林贡人的空间。进入敌方空间将被视为战争行为。但这并不是一艘真正的飞船。这是一个模拟程序。这是一个模拟程序。然而，在模拟中，如果你不进入这个敌方领土，就会有一百人死去。在现实生活中还是在模拟中？在模拟中。所以模拟程序在问你，你该怎么办？当没有好的正确答案时，你该怎么办？哦，你用小林丸策略应对它。是的，柯克船长以黑进模拟程序而闻名，他降低了
the Klingons attack shields so that he could win so that he could pass into the territory without 100 people dying and also without starting a war. And so this is the sort of cheat that Clark is calling out in his interview. But no one was ever in harm's way because it was just a practice. Lady, I will tell you again,
克林贡人的攻击护盾，以便他能够获胜，从而在没有100人死亡且没有引发战争的情况下穿过该领土。所以这就是克拉克在面试中搬出的那种作弊手段。但从来没有人处于危险之中，因为这只是一场练习。女士，我再告诉你一遍，
because you have been worried. I'm worried. It is a simulation the whole time. You will not accept that it was a simulation. Okay, okay. No one was ever gonna be harmed, lady. Okay, all right. Also, if it wasn't a simulation, it's still a TV show.
因为你一直在担心。我很担心。从头到尾都只是一个模拟程序。你就是不接受那只是个模拟程序。好吧，好吧。从来没有人会受到伤害，女士。好吧，好吧。另外，如果这不是个模拟程序，它也仍然是一部电视剧。
Well, yes. So, in either scenario, simulation or not, it's just a television show storyline, and everyone was always safe. Everyone's okay. Including people from this made up universe that doesn't exist. Okay, thank you.
好吧，是的。所以，在任何一种情况下，无论是不是模拟程序，它都只是一部电视剧的故事情节，每个人一直都很安全。大家都安然无恙。包括来自这个不存在的虚构宇宙的人。好吧，谢谢。
Good, don't worry. I needed to get that out of the way. You are so sweet in your worry about them. Well, Jenna, on that note, I think we should take a break. And when we come back, I have a Mallard update. No, you do not. I do.
很好，不用担心。我总算把这事说清楚了。你为他们担心真是太贴心了。好了，珍娜，顺着这个话题，我想我们应该休息一下。当我们回来时，我有一个关于“绿头鸭”的最新消息。不，你没有。我真的有。
We get to find out about the band Mallard today? I did not know this was coming. Sort of. You'll see. Oh, no. We'll be right back. All right, we are back. And I've never been so excited for an update about something in my life. No pressure.
我们今天要了解绿头鸭乐队的消息吗？我之前不知道有这出。算是吧。你会看到的。噢，不。我们马上回来。好了，我们回来了。我从来没有对生活中某件事的最新消息感到如此兴奋。没有压力。
Well, this is definitely going to be a letdown. I'm just going to put that out there. Or maybe you tell me. So a few weeks ago, we got a question about the mallard duck in the suit warehouse episode. We did a side-by-side, is it the same duck that Dwight used to spy on Jim? And then we got a request to do a little deep dive
好吧，这绝对会让人失望的。我先直说吧。或者也许你来告诉我。所以几周前，我们收到了一个关于西装仓库那一集里的绿头鸭的问题。我们做了一个对比，这跟德怀特用来监视吉姆的那只鸭子是同一只吗？然后我们收到了一个请求，要求对绿头鸭进行一番深度挖掘，
on mallard ducks, which I did. And I shared a stat that I found on allaboutbirds.org that said the oldest known mallard was a male, at least 27 years and seven months old, and he was shot in Arkansas in 2008. And then the stat went on to say that he had been banned from the state of Louisiana since 1981. This made Jenna and I both go, what? Why was he banned? But I didn't look it up, so I promised a follow-up. Yeah? Yep. Yep. Well, I have been keeping myself from googling it all this time. And do not Google it. I didn't. Okay. Because I got to the bottom of why this bird was banned and it's pretty embarrassing.
我照做了。我分享了一个我在allaboutbirds.org上找到的统计数据，上面说已知最长寿的绿头鸭是一只雄性，至少27岁零7个月大，它于2008年在阿肯色州被枪杀。然后统计数据接着说，自1981年以来它就被路易斯安那州禁止入境。这让珍娜和我俩都惊呼，什么？为什么它被禁了？但我当时没有查证，所以我承诺会做一个后续跟进。是吗？对。对。好吧，我一直忍着没有去谷歌搜索这事。而且千万别去谷歌搜。我没搜。好吧。因为我查到了这只鸟被禁的真相，而且这相当尴尬。
What? Not for the mallard. Oh. But for me. What is it? Well, you know, when I finish my document each week for the podcast, I go through and I do a misspelling and typo pass. No. No. And well, Microsoft Word suggested the correct spelling and I hit fine. Here's how it actually
什么？不是对绿头鸭而言。哦。是对我而言。是什么？好吧，你知道的，每当我为播客完成每周的文档时，我会通读一遍并进行拼写错误和错别字检查。不会吧。不会吧。好吧，微软Word建议了正确的拼写，我直接点了采用。以下是它在网站上的实际
read on the website. No. The mallard had been banded from the state of Louisiana since 1981. Banded, not banned. I wanna apologize to the mallard bird community for that typo. And I then had to find out what it meant for a bird to be banded. And here's what I found out.
内容。不。那只绿头鸭自1981年起就被路易斯安那州给“做上了鸟志环”。是 banded（做上鸟志环），不是 banned（禁止入境）。我要为那个错别字向绿头鸭鸟类社群道歉。然后我不得不去查给鸟做鸟志环是什么意思。以下是我查到的内容：
Waterfowl are banded only by federal and state agencies. They basically get this little band around their leg with a scanner code thingy so you can track them. One of the primary motivations for banding ducks is to identify the wintering areas and migration routes. They can also learn about the mallards' annual survival, their population, hunting behavior, harvest, and so much more. And probably because I felt so bad, I then went on YouTube and watched a lot of videos about duck banding and how it's done and what you learn from it. And the one I found very informative was from the New York State Department of Environmental Conservation. And I will put a link in our stories to those videos as well. You are speechless.
水鸟只有在联邦和州机构的组织下才会被做上鸟志环。它们的腿上基本上会挂上一个小环，上面带有扫描码之类的东西，这样你就可以追踪它们。给鸭子做鸟志环的主要动机之一是确定其越冬区域和迁徙路线。他们还可以了解绿头鸭的年度存活率、种群数量、狩猎行为、捕获量等等。可能因为我感到非常内疚，我随后上了YouTube，观看了大量关于鸭子鸟志环怎么做以及从中能学到什么视频。我发现非常具有启发性的一段视频来自纽约州环境保护部，我也会在我们的快拍中分享这些视频的链接。你简直无言以对。
This update exceeded my expectations. So basically, what we learned was that this bird had migrated from Louisiana. That's all. That's it. To Arkansas, not thrown out. He's not kicked out of the state of Louisiana. He just flew to Arkansas. His mistake though, he was doing okay in Louisiana. He'd lived a ripe old age. Yeah. Thank you so much. Because you know what, if I had Googled band mallard from nothing Louisiana, I wouldn't have gotten the answer because it never happened. I want you to know, I typed in the band mallard duck from Louisiana in 1981, and I searched and I searched and I couldn't find
这个最新消息超出了我的预期。所以基本上，我们了解到的是这只鸟从路易斯安那州迁徙过来了。就这样。没了。飞到了阿肯色州，并没有被赶出去。它没有被路易斯安那州驱逐出境。它只是飞去了阿肯色州。不过它的错在于，它在路易斯安那州本来过得挺好的。它活到了高龄。是的。非常感谢。因为你知道吗，如果我从虚无的路易斯安那州去谷歌搜索“被禁的绿头鸭”，我根本找不到答案，因为这根本没发生过。我想让你知道，我输入了“1981年路易斯安那州被禁的绿头鸭”，我搜了又搜，却找不到
anything and it kept referring me back to this All About Birds, you know, article. And then finally I looked and it said, oh my god, it says banded. Anyway, there you go. One letter can make a difference, guys. And so one story. This is a very good reason to continue to do mailbag episodes. Because we got a question for me to look up Mallards. Yeah, and look where it led. Oh, I want you to know, I feel very well-versed on banding birds now. Sort of like, because of my shame, I really went deep into bird banding and watching videos about migration.
任何东西，它一直把我引回“全关于鸟类”的那篇（你知道的）文章。然后我终于看了一眼，上面写着，哦天哪，上面写的是 banded（带环的）。不管怎样，情况就是这样。一个字母就能带来不同，伙计们。这也是继续做“听众信箱”节目的一个绝佳理由。因为我们收到了一个让我去查绿头鸭的问题。是的，看看它把我们带到了哪里。哦，我想让你知道，我现在觉得自己对鸟类鸟志环非常精通了。有点像，因为我的羞愧，我真的深入研究了鸟类鸟志环和观看迁徙视频。
Thank you so much for that update, Angela. You're welcome. Should we get back to this episode? We should because in the conference room, a real cast of characters has gathered waiting to interview. They're all of Dwight's friends. Plus Mo's. We got a fan question from Vicki S. in Little Elm, Texas, who said, I would love to hear the story behind bringing back all the amazing characters in this episode for job interviews. This felt like such an Avengers
非常感谢你带来的这个最新消息，安杰拉。不客气。我们该回到这一集了吗？我们应该回去，因为在会议室里，聚集了一群真正的奇葩角色，正等待面试。他们全都是德怀特的朋友。还有莫斯。我们收到了来自德克萨斯州小榆树镇的维基·S的粉丝提问，她说，我很想听听这一集里把所有这些惊艳的角色带回来进行工作面试背后的故事。这感觉就像是《复仇者联盟》
ensemble moment in the best way. Please give us all the details. Vicki, I was so excited about this too. And here's how it was described in the shooting draft. Interior bullpen, the office is staring with concern at the conference room where Dwight's army of freaks is assembled. Nate, Moe's, Gabor, Zeke, Trevor, Wolf, Malvina, and Sensei Ira. Some are looking over notes, preparing nervously
全明星阵容的高光时刻，棒极了。请给我们讲讲所有细节吧。维基，我对这个也感到超级兴奋。以下是拍摄剧本中对它的描述：内景。员工办公区。办公室正满怀关切地盯着会议室，德怀特的怪胎大军就在那里集结。内特、莫斯、加博尔、赞克、特雷弗、沃尔夫、马尔维娜和气功师伊拉。有的人在翻看笔记，神经质地做着面试的准备，
to be interviewed. Others are stretching pointlessly or taking photos of everyone in the office with a cell phone. Someone eats a lunch marked Stanley. Mo's combs his hair alfalfa style. Troy Underbridge is at the water cooler filling a Ziploc sandwich bag with water. He sees Dwight. Wow. Dave Rogers also talked about this scene
有的人在毫无意义地做着伸展运动，或者用手机给办公室里的每个人拍照。有人在吃标有斯坦利名字的午餐。莫斯把他的头发梳成阿尔法法式发型。特洛伊·安德里奇在饮水机旁把一个三明治自封袋装满水。他看到了德怀特。哇。戴夫·罗吉斯也谈到了这个场景，
and what it was like to have everyone back. Here's what he said. God, it was a, that was a pretty fun episode. Getting all these people together, all these people from Dwight's past. It was kind of like a, this is your life for Dwight. It was pretty fun. This was something Greg Daniels really wanted,
以及让每个人都回归是什么感觉。他是这么说的：天哪，那真是一集非常有趣的剧集。把所有人聚在一起，所有这些来自德怀特过去的人。这有点像是德怀特的“这是你的人生”节目。非常有趣。这是格雷格·丹尼尔斯非常想实现的事情，
to have all these weirdos together in one room and see them interact with each other and with Dwight. I really liked having Rolf return and, you know, Moe's and Nate and even Trevor who was, you know, just on recently. It's just great to see these guys and interacting with Troy Underbridge and Melvina, God, Beth Grant from the dinner party episode came back and Sensei Ira from I think that was the fight where he originally showed up and you know we got some some great newcomers with Gabor and Wolf and cousin Zeke.
把所有这些怪咖聚在一个房间里，看他们彼此互动，以及他们与德怀特的互动。我真的很喜欢罗尔夫的回归，还有莫斯、内特，甚至是不久前刚登场的特雷弗。能看到这些家伙真是太棒了，还有他们与特洛伊·安德里奇和马尔维娜的互动，天哪，来自《晚宴》那一集的贝丝·格兰特也回来了，还有气功师伊拉，我想他最初出场是在那场打斗中，你知道的，我们还迎来了加博尔、沃尔夫和表弟赞克这些非常棒的新面孔。
Yeah this was a this episode was actually a delight to direct it was it was really fun. And all of the actors were really, really up for it. They were just excited. Everybody was so excited to be there. And they knew we were kind of doing something special, just having all of these, you know, Dwight friends together.
是的，这一集导演起来其实是一种享受，真的非常有趣。所有的演员也都非常、非常配合。他们都超级兴奋。每个人能在那里都感到非常激动。他们知道我们在做一些特别的事情，把所有这些德怀特的朋克朋友们聚在一起。
Side note, James Urbaniak, who plays Rolf, is originally from New Jersey. And his father, Frank, ran the Marlboro Recreation Summer Camp program that I went to for many summers as a kid. So we chatted a little bit about his dad and the camp that I went to. That's quite the cast of characters. I will also add that ultimately he day interviews as well. Yes.
顺便说一句，扮演罗尔夫的詹姆斯·乌尔巴尼亚克原本来自新泽西州。他的父亲弗兰克经营着万宝路休闲夏令营项目，我小时候在那里度过了很多个夏天。所以我们稍微聊了一下他的父亲和我去过的夏令营。这真是一群奇葩角色。我还要补充一点，最终他也进行了白天的面试。是的。
Well, I asked E. Burgess about how this came about as well, and he said that Greg and the writers made a list of everyone that they would want for the episode. And like you mentioned earlier, Angela, we shot this during the second week of December, but Allison Jones started reaching out to people the week before Thanksgiving. We almost never reached out to people that early for things, but Steve Burgess said Allison and her associate Ben did an amazing job of trying to coordinate everyone's schedule to see who could be available
好吧，我问过E·伯吉斯这件事是怎么促成的，他说格雷格和编剧们列出了一份他们希望在这集中出现的所有人的名单。就像你刚才提到的，安杰拉，我们是在12月第二周拍摄的，但艾莉森·琼斯在感恩节前一周就开始联系大家了。我们几乎从不那么早就为了事情联系别人，但史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，艾莉森和她的同事本在试图协调每个人的日程安排、看谁能在这周拍摄时到场方面，做得非常出色。
this same week of shooting. Steve said they booked 19 non-regular actors for this episode, and in the end, basically what they did was they wrote for who they could get. So there were some people that they were trying to get that they did not ultimately get. Steve Burgess also said that the most difficult person
史蒂夫说他们为这一集预定了19名非固定演员，最后，基本上他们是根据能请到谁来写剧本的。所以有些人他们试图邀请但最终没能请到。史蒂夫·伯吉斯还说，最难敲定档期的人
to schedule was Mike Schur as Moe's because he was actively working on parks and recreation. But they made it work. I'm sure Mike was so excited to get dressed back up as Moe's. I know. Well, everyone else in the bullpen is looking in to the conference room and they're not happy about it. They say they don't want to judge, but these people smell. Meredith says, hey, if I ever get that bad, will you tell me? And Kevin goes, I tell you this all the time, Meredith.
是饰演莫斯的迈克·舒尔，因为他当时正在积极参与《公园与游憩》的制作。但他们最终搞定了。我敢肯定迈克重新穿上莫斯的衣服一定超级激动。我知道。好吧，办公区里的其他所有人都在往会议室里瞧，他们对此很不高兴。他们说他们不想评判别人，但这些人身上有味道。梅雷迪思说，嘿，如果我有一天变得那么糟，你们会告诉我吗？凯文说，我一直都在告诉你这个，梅雷迪思。
I know. And she says, walked right into that one. I love that exchange. Well, we asked Dave about directing this episode and any shots that stood out to him, and he mentioned this scene. Here's what he had to say. You know, from a directing standpoint, I don't really have any groundbreaking shots or any crazy camera moves or even, you know, strange editing things in this episode. You know, most of the action takes place in the conference room, the bullpen and Andy's office. But I will say I do get a kick out of the shots of the the weirdos in the conference
我知道。然后她说，自己撞枪口上了。我太喜欢这段对话了。好吧，我们问了戴夫关于导演这一集的感受，以及有哪些让他印象深刻的镜头，他提到了这个场景。他是这样说的：你知道的，从导演的角度来看，这一集中我并没有什么开创性的镜头、疯狂的运镜，甚至没有奇怪的剪辑手法。你知道的，大部分动作都发生在会议室、员工办公区和安迪的办公室里。但我必须说，我对那些
room where the main cast is just looking at them from the bullpen. It's like they're looking at a zoo or a fish tank behind the glass window and they're just yeah it's like looking at a zoo. I totally get that. Yeah. Mo's is up next for his interview and he's really patted his resume. Dwight's like why would you put this on there? We live together. I know everything about you. Yes, so Moe's does what Moe's does, and he runs away.
会议室里怪咖们的镜头确实挺有感觉的，主要演员们就从员工办公区看着他们。这就像他们在看一个动物园，或者看玻璃窗后面的一个鱼缸，他们就——是的，就像在看一个动物园。我完全理解那种感觉。是的。莫斯接下来要进行面试了，他的简历写得相当浮夸。德怀特说你为什么要写这个上去？我们住在一起。关于你的一切我都门儿清。是的，所以莫斯发挥了莫斯的本色，他逃跑了。
Yes. Steve Burgess said we had to use a photo double for that part. That's not Mike Schur running. No way. They really got the Moe's rundown, whoever they were. I know. Clark watches Moe's out the window, and then he's going to ask everyone how they heard
是的。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说那个部分我们必须用替身演员。那不是迈克·舒尔在跑。绝不可能。不管是谁，他们真的把莫斯的逃跑神韵抓住了。我知道。克拉克看着莫斯跑出窗外，然后他开始问大家是怎么听说
about this position. Nate's response is my favorite line in the entire episode and I'm going to play it. Okay. So how'd you guys hear about the position? My mom, Dwight called my house but he didn't realize that I had already moved out because my mom and I are quarreling because I can't stay out of her stuff. Yeah. I can't stay out of her stuff.
这个职位的。内特的回答是我整集中最喜欢的一句台词，我要把它放出来。好吧。所以你们是怎么听说这个职位的？我妈妈，德怀特打了我家电话，但他没意识到我已经搬出去了，因为我和我妈妈在吵架，因为我管不住自己的手，总去翻她的东西。对。我管不住自己的手。
It made me laugh so hard. Like what is he getting into? Her Tupperware? Like what is he messing with that she's like, you're out? We're also going to learn in this scene that Dwight attended a special school where he would learn to harness his mutant abilities. Mm-hmm. And it just turned out to be run by a con man.
这把我笑得前仰后合的。他到底在翻什么？她的特百惠保鲜盒？他到底在乱动什么东西，以至于她会说：你给我搬出去？我们在这场戏中还将了解到，德怀特曾就读于一所特殊的学校，他在那里学习如何驾驭自己的变种人能力。嗯哼。结果发现那是由一个骗子经营的。
Go figure. No kidding. In this next scene, Angela is not having it now. She says, someone needs to do something before I am stuck working next to one of these people for the next 20 years. 20 years? Angela Martin is in it for the long haul. She sure is.
难怪如此。一点没错。在接下来的这场戏中，安杰拉彻底受不了了。她说，在我被迫跟这些家伙之一共事二十年之前，得有人做点什么。二十年？安杰拉·马丁这是要奉陪到底啊。她当然是的。
And now everyone's about to turn on Jim. Yes. It's because of Jim that now they might have to work with one of these oddballs that Dwight's bringing in. Well, we got a very impressive fan catch from Maddie N. in Cocoa Beach, Florida, who said around 11 minutes and 30 seconds, when everyone is talking around Pam's desk
现在所有人都快把矛头指向吉姆了。是的。正是因为吉姆，他们现在可能不得不跟德怀特招来的这些怪咖之一共事。好吧，我们收到了来自佛罗里达州可可海滩的马迪·N发来的一个令人印象深刻的粉丝抓包，她说在大约11分30秒时，当大家都在帕姆的桌子周围讨论
about who the next hire will be, Pam says, quote, I'm in a position to vote for Nate, and that just feels wrong. But her lips move differently, like what she's really saying is that just feels weird. Am I crazy for seeing that? Am I completely making this up? Or did Jenna actually say weird instead of wrong
谁将是下一个被雇用的人时，帕姆说：“引述一下，我有资格投票支持内特，但这感觉不对。”但她的嘴唇动得很不一样，看起来她真正说的是“但这感觉怪怪的”。我看到这个是我疯了吗？我是完全凭空捏造的吗？还是说珍娜其实说的是“怪怪的”而不是“不对”，
and have to fix it in a voiceover? Maddie, I watched it. That last word of my line is 100% dubbed. It's a dub catch. Why? Why were you dubbing? I don't know because I looked at the script and my line was supposed to be. That just feels off. I was supposed to say off. I wasn't supposed to be, that just feels off.
并且不得不在画外音里进行修复？马迪，我看了。我那句台词的最后一个词百分之百是后期配音的。这是一个配音抓包。为什么？你为什么要配音？我不知道，因为我看了剧本，我的台词本应该是。这感觉有点不合适。我本应该说“不合适”。我本不应该说——这感觉不对。
I was supposed to say off. I wasn't supposed to say weird or wrong. Huh. I don't know why we did this. I don't remember going in and doing any kind of dubbing. So I think they must have grabbed that word from a different take and put it on this take. Yeah.
我本应该说“不合适”。我本不应该说“怪怪的”或者“不对”。哈。我不知道我们当时为什么要这么做。我不记得自己曾经去录过任何配音。所以我想他们一定是从另一个镜头里抓取了那个词，然后贴到了这个镜头上。是的。
That's what I think. That's a good catch. It's a really good catch. Oh my gosh, the next scene is just cringe at Jim's desk with the call with David Wallace. Oh yeah. Oh my goodness. This is when Jim calls David Wallace because he's trying to get some say in who is hired so he can protect Pam. Yeah. But instead, he's gonna learn that number one, David Wallace is gonna cut his pay in half
我也是这么想的。这是一个很棒的抓包。这真的是个很棒的抓包。天哪，下一场戏在吉姆的桌子上简直让人尴尬得脚趾抠地，那通和戴夫·华莱士的电话。哦，是的。哦，天哪。这就是吉姆给戴夫·华莱士打电话的时候，因为他试图在谁被录用这件事上有发言权，这样他就能保护帕姆。是的。但相反，他得知第一，戴夫·华莱士要将他的薪水减半
to pay for this replacement. And two, he tries to ask David to be an investor, an athlete, and David like cuts him off mid-sentence. I know. And Dwight is just rolling on the floor. He's so happy. Pam has gotten fed up and decides to go to the warehouse. She's down there.
来支付这个替代者的薪水。第二，他试图请戴夫成为一项体育事业的投资者，而戴夫直接在他话说了一半时打断了他。我知道。而德怀特在地上笑得打滚。他太高兴了。帕姆已经忍无可忍，决定去仓库。她在那下面。
She's going to be working on her mural and he day has a lot of notes for her. Yeah. And she's like, you know what? Thank you. Why don't you go upstairs and interview for the new position? They're hiring.
她打算去画她的壁画，而内特对她有很多意见。是的。然后她说，你知道吗？谢谢你。你为什么不上去为新职位面试呢？他们在招人。
He's genuinely thankful. He's like, thank you for this information. I will. We're now gonna see a montage of all of Dwight's odd friends doing things around the office. One is drying his pants in the bathroom. Another one is at the vending
他是发自内心地感激。他说，谢谢你告诉我这个消息。我会的。我们接下来会看到一个蒙太奇，展示了德怀特所有那些怪异的朋友在办公室里做各种事情。一个人在洗手间里烘干裤子。另一个人在自动售货机旁。
machine. One tries to touch Darryl's hair. And the rest of the coworkers have had it. Jim Nilly and Darryl find Dwight in the kitchen and they confront him about it. Yeah. So we got this fan catch from Chris K. in Vancouver, British Columbia, who said, at 13 minutes and 55 seconds, who said, at 13 minutes and 55 seconds, is Phyllis sitting in the back annex by HR? Why would she be back there? And I looked at Angela and she is, she's sitting right there. Yes, well, I have the answer for you.
一个人试图去摸达里尔的头发。而其他同事已经忍无可忍了。吉姆、内特和达里尔在厨房找到了德怀特，并就此质问他。是的。所以我们收到了来自不列颠哥伦比亚省温哥华市的克里斯·K发来的粉丝抓包，她说，在13分55秒时，菲莉丝怎么坐在人力资源部旁边的后 annex（侧厅）里？她为什么会坐在那里？我看了安杰拉的画面，她确实坐在那儿。是的，好吧，我来为你解答。
There was a really big storyline for Aaron, Pete and Phyllis in this episode. It went through the entire episode, and the whole thing was cut. There's a lot of it in deleted scenes. If you have the DVDs, I'd like to play you two clips from it that really set up the storyline. Great.
这一集里其实有一条关于艾伦、皮特和菲莉丝的非常重大的故事线。这条线贯穿了整集，但最后全部被剪掉了。删除片段里有很多这方面的内容。如果你有DVD，我想给你播放其中两个真正奠定这条故事线基础的片段。太棒了。
The storyline all starts because Aaron is trying to get a bank account, and Pete is helping her online set it up. And here are the clips. Now you just need a password. Needs to be six letters long, at least one capital, and a number. A, B, C, D, E, F, Washington, DC, six.
故事线的起因是艾伦试图开设一个银行账户，皮特正在网上帮她设置。以下是这些片段。现在你只需要一个密码。需要是六个字母长，至少有一个大写字母和一个数字。A、B、C、D、E、F、华盛顿特区、数字六。
Pete is helping me get a bank account online. It's official. I'm a nerd now. So security questions. What was your mother's maiden name? I don't know. Okay, how about...what's your father's occupation? No clue. I don't know who my dad is. Oh, that's right. I'm sorry.
皮特正在帮我在网上开通一个银行账户。这下官方了。我现在是个书呆子了。所以是安全问题。你母亲的婚前姓氏是什么？我不知道。好吧，那……你父亲的职业是什么？没头绪。我不知道我爸是谁。哦，对哦。对不起。
What is the middle name of your oldest sibling? I don't know if I have one. What street was your first home on? What is the middle name of your oldest sibling? I don't know if I have one. What street was your first home on? Wow, they do not make these orphan friendly, do they? Mm-mm. Aw, I know. So then Erin decides to approach Phyllis because she knows Phyllis had a child
你最大的兄弟姐妹的中间名是什么？我不知道我有没有兄弟姐妹。你的第一个家在什么街道上？你最大的兄弟姐妹的中间名是什么？我不知道我有没有兄弟姐妹。你的第一个家在什么街道上？哇，他们设计这些问题可真对孤儿不友好，对吧？嗯-嗯。哦，我知道。所以艾伦决定去找菲莉丝，因为她知道菲莉丝生孩子的时间和艾伦出生的时候是同一时期，也许菲莉丝能有一些关于艾伦身世背景的线索，于是他们去找了菲莉丝。菲莉丝说她很抱歉什么都不记得了，也帮不上忙，但随后她想起来，哦，等等，我妈把我生孩子的过程录成录像带了，当时我正是在那家医院，也许这段录像里会有能成为艾伦线索的东西。然后休息室里有一场戏。里面有一个重大旧科技警报，因为上面写着：一台旧电视机连接着一台Betamax录像机。菲莉丝、皮特和艾伦
the same time Erin was born, and maybe Phyllis might have some clues as to Erin's origin story, so they approach Phyllis. Phyllis says she's sorry she can't remember anything and she can't help them but then she remembers oh wait my mom videotaped my childbirth and I was at the hospital maybe there's something in this video footage that will be a clue for Aaron. And then there's a scene in the break room. It's got a major old tech alert because it says, an old TV is hooked up to a Betamax machine. Phyllis, Pete and Aaron
看着菲莉丝的录像带。你永远看不到屏幕上播的是什么。你只能看到他们的反应。然后艾伦说，这要持续多久啊？菲莉丝说，哦，我阵痛了56个小时。然后达里尔走进来，一脸“你们在看什么”的表情，他被吓坏了。最后是以育儿室里所有婴儿的视频巡礼结束。里面有一个顶着一头红发的小婴儿。他们所有人当场把电视画面定格，面面相觑，仿佛在说：哦天哪，那是艾伦吗？所以这是一条非常庞大的故事线。好吧，我记得，安杰拉，
watch Phyllis' videotape. You never see what's on the screen. You just see them reacting to it. And Aaron goes, how long does this go on for? And Phyllis says, oh, I was in labor for 56 hours. And then Darrell walks in and he's like, what are you guys watching? And he's like freaked out. And then it ends with like a video tour of the nursery of all the babies. And there's a little redheaded baby. And they kind of all freeze the TV and look at each other like, oh my gosh, is that Aaron? So it was a huge storyline. Well, I remember Angela,
当我读到那个粉丝提问时，我也去查了剧本。他们看完录像后，意识到她是在某家特定的医院出生的。所以她和皮特去那家医院附近的街区散步。他们纳闷，哦，这会不会是她长大的地方？这是她的背景吗？
and when I read that fan question, I went to the script as well. And after they see the video, they realize she was born at this one particular hospital. So her and Pete go take a walk in the neighborhood near the hospital. And they wonder like, oh, is this maybe where she grew up? Is this her background?
对。她的街区。有一个非常温馨的台词，育儿室婴儿床上的名牌上只写着“圣玛格丽特”，艾伦说：“哦，我原本的名字叫圣玛格丽特。我猜我小时候一定是个非常虔诚的婴儿。”是的。菲莉丝说：“不，亲爱的，我想那是教堂的名字。”好吧，我们问过戴夫·罗吉斯关于这件事，他给我们发来一段音频片段，解释了为什么整条故事线、这条精心制作的故事线会被剪掉。他是这么说的：你知道的，在我们的剧集中，剧本往往比最终电视播出 allotted（分配的）时间要长得多。所以很多内容都会被剪掉。
Right. Her neighborhood. There's a very sweet line where in the nursery on the crib, the name just says St. Margaret's and Erin goes, oh, my original name was St. Margaret's. I guess I was a really religious baby. Yes. And Phyllis was like, no, honey, I think that's the church. Well, we asked Dave Rogers about this, and he sent us in an audio clip explaining why this entire storyline, this very elaborate storyline was cut. Here's what he had to say. You know, often in our episodes, we have scripts that are way, way longer than the time allotted to the final broadcast of the television show. So a lot of stuff gets cut out.
有时这里或那里会删掉一个小节、一个副线、一个场景或多个场景。在这种情况下，我们最终从这集中删除了整整一条故事线，内容是关于艾伦和皮特探索艾伦作为孤儿的经历。他们去找菲莉丝谈话。这是一个很棘手的故事。我想我们都尽最大努力去呈现它了，杰克和埃莉的表现也很棒。我们确实看到他们以一种很好的方式建立联系，但归根结底，这个故事涉及到艾伦是个孤儿，而且在寻找父母或其他真实信息方面没有取得任何实质进展，
Sometimes there's a beat here and there or a runner or a scene or multiple scenes. In this case, we ended up removing an entire storyline from the episode, which had Aaron and Pete exploring Aaron being an orphan. They go to talk to Phyllis. This was a tricky story. I think we all did our best to execute it, and Jake and Ellie do a great job. We really get to see them connecting in a nice way, but ultimately the story deals with Aaron being an orphan, and not getting any closer to finding her parents or any other real information
只是，它并不是那么令人满意。在她是个孤儿与菲莉丝放弃了一个孩子之间，也有一种悲伤的基调，这在加长版剧集中可能会更有效，因为在那里面情节可以稍微展开一些，同时我们还有德怀特的故事带来的喜剧效果，但在一个21到35分钟的剧集里，它感觉实在太沉重了。在加长版剧集中，情节可以稍微展开一些，同时我们还有德怀特的故事带来的喜剧效果，但在一个21到35分钟的剧集里，它感觉实在太沉重了。我确实让埃莉和杰克知道我们最终把它剪掉了，我向他们解释了
Just it wasn't very satisfying There's also a sad undertone between her being an orphan and Phyllis giving up a baby that it just It might have worked better in a super sized episode where the beats are a little bit more spread out while we have the comedy of the Dwight Story, but in a 21 35 minute episode it just felt really heavy Super-sized episode where the beats are a little bit more spread out while we have the comedy of the Dwight story But in a 21 35 minute episode, it just felt really heavy I did let Ellie and Jake know that we ended up cutting it and I explained The same reasons I'm telling you now and I reassured them that what they were doing together was great and to keep doing it As the you know, their storyline keeps moving on but this was just a matter of this particular story and the time that we had for the show and that we just couldn't trim out a beat here or there in their story.
我现在告诉你们的相同原因，并且向他们保证，他们在一起所做的事情非常棒，要继续坚持下去，因为（你知道的）他们的故事线在不断推进，但这次只是这个特定故事以及我们为节目拥有的时间的问题，我们实在无法在他们的故事里随意修剪这里或那里的某个情节。
It was like every beat depended on the beat before. It was very linear. So that's what happened. We ended up cutting this whole storyline out and just focused more on Dwight and his freaky friends and had a little room in there for, you know, the Pam, Brian, Jim relationship arc. You know, it is so like Dave to reach out to us if he ever had to cut something that we had done, he would always reassure us just so you know this wasn't your performance. Yeah.
就像每一个情节都依赖于前一个情节一样。它是非常线性的。所以这就是发生的事情。我们最终剪掉了整条故事线，把更多精力集中在德怀特和他的怪胎朋友身上，并在其中腾出一点空间来展现（你知道的）帕姆、布赖恩和吉姆的关系弧线。你知道的，戴夫就是这样一个人，如果他不得不剪掉我们拍的东西，他总是会主动联系我们给我们吃定心丸，好让你们知道这绝对不是你们表演的问题。是的。
This was a story thing, this was a time thing, this was a whatever. We just didn't have time to tell this story. Yeah, he's a standup guy that way. Yeah. Now Dwight is gonna interview Wolf, but this interview goes off the rails really quickly. Yeah, it really does.
这是故事层面的事，是时间层面的事，是别的什么事。我们只是没有时间来讲述这个故事。是的，他在为人处世上就是这么光明磊落。是的。现在德怀特要去面试沃尔夫了，但这场面试急转直下，很快就失控了。是的，确实如此。
And I think Dwight's starting to get nervous. He's now gonna interview Hide. Yep. And that doesn't work out either. So Dwight is in the conference room and he's got this sort of like cork board and he has the name of all the different applicants on the board
而且我觉得德怀特开始紧张了。他现在要面试希德。没错。那也没成功。所以德怀特在会议室里，他弄了块类似软木板的东西，上面写着所有不同应聘者的名字，
and he's saying I just can't seem to decide here's the little tidbit I teased earlier and remember when we were at lunch with Dave yeah yes and he told us how they didn't confirm Rolf for the episode they didn't have James Urbaniak confirmed to be in the episode until after we already started shooting the episode. Yeah, he wasn't even on set till like day two or something. Yes, but Dave told us he was so hopeful that it would work out that he shot this scene with a blank note card up in the corner and he wrote Rolf on it in post. That's right. That's right. He put a little placeholder just in case they got him on that cork board.
他说我在这里实在做不出决定，这就是我之前卖的关子，还记得我们在跟戴夫吃午饭的时候吗？是的，他告诉我们他们是如何没有最终确认罗尔夫出演这一集的，直到我们已经开始拍摄这一集之后，他们才让詹姆斯·乌尔巴尼亚克确认出演。是的，他直到第二天左右才到片场。是的，但戴夫告诉我们，他非常希望事情能成，所以他在角落里挂了一张空白便签卡拍了这场戏，然后在后期制作中把“罗尔夫”的名字写了上去。没错。没错。他在那块软木板上放了一个小占位符，以防万一能把他请来。
Yes. Dwight's in a tough spot now. He's actually kind of rolling around on the floor in Andy's office and Melvina wants to know if he needs to be changed. He says no, he does that himself now and she says, well, are you going to have a decision soon because I've been double parked for five hours? And Dwight's like, no, your car's been towed by now. And then a few more of his friends come in, and they promise, listen, no matter who you choose, we'll still be your friend.
是的。德怀特现在处境艰难。他实际上在安迪的办公室里在地板上滚来滚去，马尔维娜想知道他是否需要换尿布。他说不，他现在自己能做这个了，然后她说，好吧，你很快就会做决定吗？因为我双排停车已经五个小时了。德怀特说，不，你的车现在已经被拖走了。然后他的几个朋友走了进来，他们承诺，听好了，无论你选谁，我们仍然是你的朋友。
And Dwight's like, yeah, I mean, even if I choose none of you, they say, well, that wouldn't happen. You wouldn't drag us all down here and waste all of our time to pick none of us. Yeah, that would be insulting. So Dwight is gonna have to team up with Jim. Yes, he's gonna seek out his enemy because he has no choice.
德怀特说，是的，我的意思是，即使我谁都不选，他们说，那不会发生。你不会把我们所有人都拖到这里来，浪费我们所有人的时间，结果却谁都不选。是的，那太侮辱人了。所以德怀特不得不和吉姆联手。是的，他要去找他的死敌，因为他别无选择。
And he says, Jim, will you please pick someone? And he basically says, I don't want to hire any of these people. You can hire Clark, but you have to break the news to everyone. And we're going to make it seem like it was your decision. Dwight says, it turns out my standards for coworkers are higher than my standards for friends. He couldn't imagine any of them in the old golden gray. And yes, he did design uniforms for Dunder Mifflin.
他说，吉姆，求你选个人吧！他基本上是说，我不想雇佣这些人中的任何一个。你可以雇佣克拉克，但你必须把这个消息告诉所有人。我们要让它看起来像是你作出的决定。德怀特说，事实证明，我对同事的标准比对朋友的标准还要高。他无法想象他们当中有谁能穿上老式的金色灰色制服。是的，他确实为邓德米夫林设计过制服。
Yeah, he has a talking head. He shows us the uniforms. They are summer, winter, jungle, and formal. We got a fan question from Megan B. in Toronto and Martha B. in Malta who said, who drew the Dunder Mifflin uniforms and were they given any instructions by the writers? Well, this was such a quick pop, but I loved it so much.
是的，他有一个独白镜头。他向我们展示了这些制服。分为夏季、冬季、丛林和正装。我们收到了来自多伦多的梅根·B和马耳他的玛莎·B的粉丝提问，她们说，谁画了邓德米夫林制服，他们在创作时是否得到了编剧的任何指示？好吧，这个镜头一闪而过，但我太喜欢了。
I went to the script. There was not a description for these drawings in the script. Steve Burgess thinks that Alicia, our costume designer, might've drawn these. And we asked Dave Rogers, he couldn't remember who drew them, but he did have a fun tidbit to share. Here's what he said. One of the things that was really fun was Dwight's talking head where he shows off sketches of Dundermifflin uniforms
我去看了一下剧本。剧本里对这些画没有进行描述。史蒂夫·伯吉斯认为，我们的服装设计师艾丽西亚可能画了这些。我们问过戴夫·罗杰斯，他不记得是谁画的了，但他有一个有趣的八卦要分享。他是这么说的。其中一件很有趣的事就是德怀特的个人独白，他在独白中展示了邓德米夫林制服的草图
that he designed. I do remember giving small notes to color them in so they'd read better on camera that they weren't just like you know pencil sketches. What's really interesting is that when we got into editing, Greg actually thought they were too fashionable and he had us reshoot with new versions and so we have we had alternate versions. We shot a new version of the talking head where the uniforms really leaned more into the military. The summer outfit was practically a, how do you pronounce it, a ghillie suit.
他设计的。我确实记得给过一些小意见，让他们把颜色填上，这样在镜头前效果会更好，不只是那种铅笔草图。真正有趣的是，当我们进入剪辑阶段时，格雷格其实觉得它们太时尚了，他让我们用新版本重新拍摄，所以我们有备用版本。我们重拍了那个个人独白，制服更偏向军事风格。夏装简直就是，怎么发音来着，吉利服。
But after seeing the new costumes, he changed his mind. And so he liked the original costumes better and that's what you see in the show. I think I have pictures of the alternate ones. I will send that to you guys. So Dave is so amazing. And you know what? He saves everything too, Jenna. We're kind of both like that. You are digital clutter buddies. We are, except his are organized. It's true. But you know, I looked at all of those sketches and they did remind me so much of the sketches that I saw Alicia do over the years. Mm-hmm, me too.
但在看到新服装后，他改变了主意。所以他更喜欢最初的服装，这就是你在剧里看到的。我想我有那些备用服装的照片。我会发给你们的。戴夫真是太棒了。而且你知道吗？他什么都留着，珍娜。我们俩都有点这样。你是数字杂物好搭档。我们确实是，不过他的整理得井井有条。确实如此。不过你知道，我看了所有这些草图，它们真的让我想起了我多年来看到艾丽西亚画的草图。嗯嗯，我也是。
She's such a good artist and it had her sort of style, so I feel like they were hers. But I will put them in stories so you guys can all see. Next up, Jim is gonna break the news to all of the applicants. He says, I am hiring none of you. Dwight pretends to be outraged. Jem's like, tone it down. Tone it down.
她是个非常棒的艺术家，而且有她的那种风格，所以我觉得这些就是她画的。但我会把它们发到快拍里，这样你们大家都能看到了。接下来，吉姆要向所有申请人宣布消息了。他说，你们谁我都不会雇佣。德怀特假装非常愤怒。杰姆说，声音小点。声音小点。
Yes, exactly. Rolf is like, I know what this was. I know you're behind this. I wouldn't open any suspicious packages, or maybe you should open them. You do not want to cross Rolf. You do not. All of Dwight's friends start to leave,
对，没错。罗尔夫说，我知道这是怎么回事。我知道你在背后搞鬼。我可不会打开任何可疑的包裹，或者也许你应该打开它们。你可不想惹罗尔夫。真的不想。德怀特的所有朋友开始离开，
and they're kind of unsure what they're going to do for the rest of the day. Then they decide to not. All of Dwight's friends start to leave and they're kind of unsure what they're gonna do for the rest of the day. Then they decide to go paintball without Dwight. He is bummed. And Creed as they leave kind of sneakily joins them in leaving. Yes we got a fan catch from Emily B in San Diego and St. Louis who said I'm not the best at fan catches, so I was pretty darn proud of myself for noticing this one. Dwight's friends all leave to play paintball, and we see Creed run out after them, presumably to join them. But when Dwight later gets an email with a picture of the group, Creed isn't in the photo. Maybe Creed just used the opportunity to get out of work early.
他们有点不确定今天剩下时间该做什么。然后他们决定不去。德怀特的所有朋友开始离开，他们有点不确定今天剩下时间该做什么。然后他们决定抛下德怀特去玩真人CS。他很沮丧。克里德在他们离开时，鬼鬼祟祟地加入了他们的行列。是的，我们收到了来自圣地亚哥和圣路易斯的埃米莉·B的粉丝发现，她说我不太擅长发现这些细节，所以我为自己能注意到这个而感到相当骄傲。德怀特的朋友们都去玩真人CS了，我们看到克里德跑出去追他们，大概是想加入他们。但当德怀特后来收到一封附有合影的邮件时，克里德却不在照片里。也许克里德只是利用这个机会早点下班。
Emily, I think you're right. I think Creed was just a plain hooky. No, ladies, he actually went. But he's not in the picture. I know. Here's how it was in the shooting draft. There was a tag written for the episode where they all go and play paintball, and it said, exterior paintball field day.
埃米莉，我觉得你说得对。我觉得克里德只是逃了个旷工。不，女士们，他真的去了。但他不在照片里。我知道。拍摄剧本里是这样的。这一集原本写了一个彩蛋，他们所有人都去玩真人CS了，上面写着，外景，真人CS场地，白天。
Creed is on his knees begging for his life as Wolf holds a paintball gun to his head. Gabor stands nearby. It's also in deleted scenes and I'm going to play it for you. Please I don't know where my teammates are or what we're doing. Is this a game? Am I having fun? He doesn't need to tell us what he's thinking, so I could read his mind. It helps if you kind of mouth what you're thinking. Hey guys, there's a creek over there, and well, I almost drowned. Ah, wolf! I'm on your team! Wolf!
克里德跪在地上苦苦求饶，沃尔夫把真人CS枪顶在他脑门上。加博尔站在旁边。这也出现在删减片段里，我要放给你们听。求求你们，我不知道我的队友在哪儿，也不知道我们在干什么。这是个游戏吗？我玩得开心吗？他不需要告诉我们他在想什么，所以我能读懂他的心思。如果你把心里想的话稍微动嘴说出来会有所帮助。嘿，伙计们，那边有一条小溪，然后，我差点淹死。啊，沃尔夫！我和你一队的！沃尔夫！
Wolfman's gone rogue, and now, you die. Okay, I'll tell everyone everything. The hobbit and the old woman are hiding in the porta potty. Oh my gosh, so I knew about this tag lady but I didn't know Creed was in it. Yes, and Creed ultimately gives up Melvina and Troy. I guess they were hiding in the porta potty like you said. But here's my Troy. I guess they were hiding in the porta potty, like he said. But here's my theory. I think Creed took the picture. Oh, that's good.
沃尔夫曼已经叛变了，现在，你死定了。好吧，我把所有事都告诉你们。那个霍比特人和那个老太婆藏在移动厕所里。哦天哪，女士们，我知道这个彩蛋，但我不知道克里德也在里面。是的，克里德最终供出了梅尔维纳和特洛伊。我猜他们就像你说的藏在移动厕所里。但这是我的特洛伊。我猜他们藏在移动厕所里，正如他所说。但这是我的理论。我觉得是克里德拍的照片。哦，这倒不错。
Uh-huh. I like that. That's why he wasn't in it. And you know, when we had lunch with Dave, he told us shooting these paintball tag scenes were his favorite. He loved it so much. He said it was just so fun to shoot something that had some action,
嗯哼。我喜欢这个。这就是他不在照片里的原因。你知道的，当我们和戴夫共进午餐时，他告诉我们拍摄这些真人CS的场景是他的最爱。他太喜欢了。他说拍摄一些带有动作戏份的场面真的很有趣，
but they ultimately didn't use it, but it is all in deleted scenes. Listen, I think that the episode ends perfectly. I think that this tag was probably really funny. And fun to do, right? They all got to be outside running around. But the way it ended was so powerful. All right, we're almost there. We are almost there. Yeah. But ooh, the way it ended was so powerful. All right, we're almost there. We are almost there. Clark gets the job and Jim is gonna help him get all set up at his desk.
但他们最终没有使用它，不过这些都在删减片段里。听着，我觉得这一集结局堪称完美。我觉得这个彩蛋可能真的很好笑。拍起来也很好玩，对吧？他们都能去室外跑来跑去。但结局的方式太震撼了。好了，我们快到了。我们真的快到了。对。但是，哦，结局的方式太震撼了。好了，我们快到了。我们真的快到了。克拉克得到了这份工作，吉姆要帮他在办公桌前安顿下来。
Pam comes back from the warehouse. She's very happy that it's Clark and not one of Dwight's friends. And Jim's gonna leave and go back to Philly. Yeah, Jim kisses her goodbye and he leaves. They're kind of sitting there in their new clump and Clark says to Pam, hey, I'm going to the kitchen, you want anything?
帕姆从仓库回来了。她很高兴得到工作的是克拉克，而不是德怀特的朋友。吉姆要离开并回费城了。对，吉姆吻别了她然后离开了。他们有点坐在他们的新堆里，克拉克对帕姆说，嘿，我要去厨房，你要点什么吗？
I think that's a good deskmate. Very nice. Yeah. Pam says she's okay. Dwight says, I would love some more coffee. But then Clark says, oh, sorry, you have to be this tall for coffee. Or he calls back that little bit that Dwight did to him
我觉得这是个不错的办公桌邻居。非常好。对。帕姆说她不用。德怀特说，我想要更多的咖啡。但接着克拉克说，哦，抱歉，喝咖啡得有这么高才行。或者他把德怀特之前对他做过的那套话
in the break room earlier. Yeah, Dwight's not cool enough for coffee. Yeah. So Pam sees that Dwight is sad and she says, hey, do you want to haze the new guy? Dwight is so tickled. Pam's like, okay, here's some Saran wrap. Next time Clark goes to the bathroom and Dwight interrupts her, he's like, okay, here's some Saran wrap. Next time Clark goes to the bathroom
在茶水间里还了回去。对，德怀特不够酷，不配喝咖啡。所以帕姆看到德怀特很难过，她就说，嘿，你想整蛊新人吗？德怀特高兴坏了。帕姆说，好吧，这里有一些保鲜膜。下次克拉克去洗手间时，德怀特打断了她，他说，好吧，这里有一些保鲜膜。下次克拉克去洗手间时
and Dwight interrupts her. He's like, no, no, don't worry. I know what to do. And they kind of get tickled. And then Clark returns to his desk and Dwight covers his face in Saran wrap. This is not the toilet. Pam meant the toilet trick.
打断了她。他说，不，不，别担心。我知道该怎么做。他们俩有点乐不可支。然后克拉克回到座位上，德怀特用保鲜膜蒙住了他的脸。这不是马桶。帕姆指的是马桶恶作剧。
So lady, I remember reading this and I remember thinking we're gonna kill thinking, we're gonna kill Clark. We're gonna kill him. Because I mean, Rain admitted that he would really go for it in scenes like this. Yes, he goes all out. Yes, so when we were planning the scene, I was like, we need a signal, we need a safe word,
所以女士们，我记得读到这里时，我记得当时想我们要弄死克拉克了。我们要弄死他。因为我的意思是，雷恩承认他在这样的场景中会非常投入。是的，他全力以赴。是的，所以当我们策划这个场景时，我在想，我们需要一个暗号，我们需要一个安全词，
we need some way that we know the difference between Clark acting and Clark actually suffocating. We also asked Dave about this scene, and here's what he had to say. Rain fully commits to being Dwight in his performance every time. And I remember being a little nervous when reading the script and it said Dwight was gonna wrap Clark's head in shrink wrap.
我们需要某种方式来区分克拉克是在演戏还是真的在窒息。我们还问了戴夫关于这个场景的事，他是这么说的。雷恩每次表演时都完全投入到德怀特这个角色中。我记得读剧本时有点紧张，上面写着德怀特要把克拉克的头用收缩膜包起来。
So of course we get to set and everyone is there telling me we need to watch Clark and make sure he can breathe. Like everybody's just anxious and nervous. So it builds up all this anxiety for this really small, I mean I wouldn't call it a stunt, this physical action between two actors on a controlled set, our little office set. I will say that they shot take one, it looked pretty good to me, and when we cut they were both laughing. And then Rain asked, you okay? And Clark was like, oh yeah, that was fine,
所以我们当然到了片场，每个人都在那儿告诉我们要盯着克拉克，确保他能呼吸。就像每个人都很焦虑和紧张。所以这就为这场非常小的戏积聚了所有的焦虑，我的意思是我不会称之为一个特技动作，这是在受控片场中两个演员之间的肢体动作，在我们的小办公室片场里。我得说他们拍了第一条，我觉得看起来挺好的，当我们喊停时他们都在笑。然后雷恩问，你还好吗？克拉克就说，哦，挺好的，那没问题，
you can go even more than that. So they did several takes, the two of them really had fun doing the gag. Clark was never in any real danger, but he sold it, that was, you know, choking and suffocating. And, you know, it was just to me, I was really happy with how it came out. It came out, you know, really, really funny. It was so realistic to me. I'd forgotten this moment, you know, and then in our rewatch,
你甚至可以再用劲一点。所以他们拍了好几条，他们俩真的玩得很开心。克拉克从来没有真正处于危险之中，但他演得很逼真，就是那种哽咽和窒息的感觉。而且，这对我来说，我对呈现出来的效果非常满意。效果真的是，非常非常搞笑。对我来说太逼真了。我都忘了这一刻了，然后在我们重看的时候，
I felt like I saw it for the first time and I was like, oh. I was in full panic attack mode the entire time we shot this scene. Oh, I bet. They sold it. My performance is my real reaction. All right, are we ready for the final moment? Yeah. Here it comes.
我感觉就像是第一次看到一样，然后我就想，哦。我们在拍这个场景的整个过程中都处于完全恐慌的状态。哦，我敢说。他们演得太好了。我的表现就是我真实的反应。好了，我们准备好迎接最后的时刻了吗？好。它来了。
Jim is gonna have a talking head. He says, of course it matters who sits next to Pam. Who you sit next to is who you spend your life with. He fell in love because he spent all those years staring at Pam. And then the camera reveals Brian holding a boom over Pam and just looking at her with such adoration and smiling. And Jim's last line of his talking head is, that stuff definitely matters. I mean, people lost their minds.
吉姆有一段个人独白。他说，谁坐在帕姆旁边当然很重要。你坐在谁旁边，你就会和谁共度一生。他坠入爱河，因为他花了那么多年凝视着帕姆。然后镜头展现出布莱恩正举着挑杆在帕姆上方，带着无比爱慕的眼神看着她并微笑着。吉姆个人独白的最后一句台词是，这真的很重要。我是说，人们都疯狂了。
Mm-hmm. Yeah. Turns out maybe Brian and Alyssa's marriage isn't as strong as we thought it was. He definitely likes looking at Pam. I have one funny behind the scenes detail about this moment. What is it? I remember when you guys were doing it, we were there.
嗯哼。是的。结果也许布莱恩和艾丽西亚的婚姻并没有我们想象的那么牢固。他确实很喜欢看着帕姆。关于这个时刻，我有一个有趣的幕后细节。是什么？我记得你们在拍的时候，我们就在那儿。
I was over in the accounting nook. You don't end up seeing us, but I'll never forget Chris. He was so funny and charming. And he was having to hold that boom over his head. And he's a super fit guy, but his arms after take after take started to shake. And he was like, I gotta rest this boom. And we all had such appreciation for our boom operators,
我在会计那边的小角落。你最后没看到我们，但我永远不会忘记克里斯。他太有趣太迷人了。他不得不把那个挑杆举过头顶。他是个身材超级健美的家伙，但一条又一条地拍下来后，他的胳膊开始发抖了。他说，我得让这个挑杆休息一下。我们对我们的挑杆操作员充满了感激，
but I think Chris above all, we're like, wow, you guys are so damn strong. Now that you say that, I do remember that. Chris was very committed. He's one of those actors, you know? He's like, if I'm playing a boom operator, I'm gonna hold the boom. I don't know if you noticed in the first scene,
但我觉得克里斯最甚，我们当时想，哇，你们这些家伙太强壮了。经你这么一说，我还真记起来了。克里斯非常投入。你知道他是那种演员吗？他会想，如果我扮演一个挑杆操作员，我就会好好举着挑杆。我不知道你们在第一个场景有没有注意到，
he's doing all that business, like wrapping up cords. Like he learned that. Yeah. You know, he was like, I business, like wrapping up cords, like he learned that. Yeah. You know, he was like, I want to look like a real boom operator. Yeah. He was very committed. Very method. Oh, well there you have it everybody. That is Junior Salesman, a big thank you to Steve Burgess and Dave Rogers and everyone for all of your letters encouraging us to keep podcasting. Yes, thank you so much. We promise we will. We're not going anywhere. And we hope you guys have a fantastic day. Know that we love you and we'll see you next week.
他在做所有那些事情，比如缠绕电线。就像他学过的一样。是的。你知道，他就好像在说，我想看起来像个真正的挑杆操作员。是的。他非常投入。非常体验派。哦，好吧，大家听到了。这就是《初级推销员》，非常感谢史蒂夫·伯吉斯、戴夫·罗杰斯以及所有人发来鼓励我们继续做播客的信件。是的，非常感谢。我们向大家保证我们会继续做下去的。我们哪儿也不去。希望大家今天过得愉快。请知道我们爱你们，我们下周见。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwulf, Jenna Fischer, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Jordan Duffy. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由 Earwulf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的资深制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是乔丹·达菲。我们的助理制作人是艾insley·布巴科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。